hey everyone
welcome to this react js crash course
react
is a javascript library used to create
fancy user interfaces
for mobile and desktop applications it
is widely used
and is preferred over other frameworks
for front-end development
so if you wish to learn web development
then you're in the right place
this video covers all the necessary
topics to give you a good understanding
of react
and some of its basic concepts so here's
a list of things we're going to be
covering in the video
first we'll begin with a quick
introduction to react
then we'll move ahead with react
installation on windows
later we'll cover topics like react
components
props and state next we're going to
build an application from scratch
after that we'll have a look at
different javascript frameworks
like react angular and view we're also
going to be covering
topics like connecting react.js with
node.js
react with redux and we'll see the
comparison between react
native and flutter and after this we'll
end this extensive session
with some interview questions all of
this under 4.5 hours
so let's begin in today's video we'll be
learning
all about react.js so let's jump in and
see what's in store for us
so we'll be covering topics on what is
react why react
features of react react prerequisites
and its industry trends
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library
used to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web
and mobile applications now one thing
that makes react
extremely powerful is the fact that it's
open source
any user can access its source code
modify it and enhance it
in a typical model view controller
architecture react defines the view part
of the application it is also
responsible for how the app looks and
feels
fun fact react was built by jordan
walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time
consider a typical web application say
instagram the entire ui
of the web page is divided into several
components we have
the search component a profile
description component stories component
and a post list component these
components make the code easier to debug
and always remain discrete
components also make development and
maintenance of web applications faster
as multiple developers can work
simultaneously on different components
of the same web application
now let's see why react is so popular
these days the act helps in creation of
dynamic web applications
it also provides performance
enhancements now there are several
performance enhancements like virtual
dom and one-way data binding
we'll learn about these topics a little
later in the video react uses reusable
components
now this helps decrease the development
time react involves unidirectional flow
of data
react also has a small learning curve
compared to other frameworks like
angular
react is much easier to learn react can
also be used for mobile applications
react recently released an extension
called react native that is used for
developing mobile applications that are
cross-compatible
it also has dedicated tools for easy
debugging
now let's dive in to the features of
react first
let's understand jsx jsx is a syntax
extension
to javascript using jsx we can add html
to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand
and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of
javascript and html now let's consider a
small example
cons simple here is a javascript
notation h1 tags
indicate html again the semicolon
indicates
javascript note that the semicolon is
not mandatory however it's a good
practice
to include it moving on the next feature
is virtual dom
dom which is an acronym for data object
model
actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom
that is the exact copy of the real dom
traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated
this makes it extremely slow let's see
how react counters this
now consider two objects whose states
have been changed
react now compares the virtual dom with
the virtual dom snapshot
that was taken right before the update
by comparing the new virtual dom with
the pre-update version
react figures out exactly which virtual
dom objects have changed
now react only updates those objects on
the virtual
dom this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed
coming to the next feature performance
react uses virtual dom
as discussed earlier virtual dog impacts
the speed of the web applications
we also took an example of instagram and
learned how multiple components can
affect the development time
they help improve performance
drastically the next feature
is one way data binding this means
information flows in only one direction
one way data binding is specifically
used when information is displayed
and not updated remember that the
components of react are functional in
nature
that is they receive information through
arguments and pass information
via their return values the next
important feature is extensions
react has many extensions that we can
use to create full-fledged front-end
applications
it provides server-side rendering which
means that the application is rendered
on the server rather than in the browser
react native which is a react extension
is used for developing mobile
applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development
now let's look at a few of them react
native lets you build mobile
applications
using only javascript a react native app
is a real mobile application
and not just a web application running
on your mobile devices
thousands of applications like facebook
instagram
pinterest skype use react native the
next
popular react extension is flux flux is
the application architecture
that facebook uses flux implements
unidirectional flow
which makes it easier to understand what
actually is going on
now let's see how it works when we
trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them
to the stores a store is what holds the
data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can
receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views
actions define the internal api of your
application
they capture how anything might interact
with your application
the last feature of react is debugging
react applications are easy to debug
thanks to the large and active developer
community you can practically debug
react codes within your browser
now notice the small react extension
icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it
moving on let's learn about the building
blocks of react
components state and props are the
essential concepts
that one should know before implementing
react they are the foundation on which
react is built
now what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application
react divides the user interface into
multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element
is viewed in the application react
components remain discrete
and are processed independently another
feature
is reusability components can be reused
multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time
consider the following code snippet a
component is implemented as a javascript
class
having some state and a render method
state is the data which we want the
component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user
the next concept is state state of a
component
is an object that holds some data this
data
influences the output of a component
every time the state of an object
changes
the component is re-rendered onto the
screen now let's see what props are
props or short for properties allow us
to pass arguments or data to components
properties help make components more
dynamic it is important to define
all the properties their types and their
default value
props are passed to components in a way
similar to that of html tag
attributes now consider the following
code snippets
this shows exactly how properties are
passed to components
also detailed illustrations on
components props and state
will be shown in the upcoming videos so
stay tuned for that
moving on let's go through some of the
things that you should know
before you can actually start working on
react you should be familiar with
programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
javascript
and a familiarity with html don't worry
if you feel like you're not good at them
once you start working on them you'll
get a good hang of it finally
let's go through the impact of react on
the it industry
and get insights into the salaries of
react developers
statistics show that react developers
earn way more than other web developers
according to pay scale the average
salary for a react developer
in the united states is a whopping 91
000 us dollars
the average salary for a react developer
in india is 7.25 lakhs per annum
over the recent years react has gained
immense popularity and is being adopted
by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks
like angular and vue statistics show
that front-end developers
have wholeheartedly adopted this
lightweight framework forgoing other
available options if you are skilled and
have a knack for front-end development
react can help you gain fantastic career
opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally
we have facebook instagram netflix
dropbox
whatsapp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows so without
further ado let's get started to set up
the react development environment
we need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice
so let's begin by installing nodejs we
can head to the official node.js website
say download node.js
so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version
so i'm going to go ahead and click on
the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node
you can follow the installation
guidelines and download it
once you're done with node installation
you can go ahead and download
a text editor of your choice so i'd
suggest vs code so let's head to
the vs code page say download vs code
click on the first link and download the
64-bit version
for windows once you're done with the
installation of both node and your text
editor you can start creating
your first react application so for that
let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it first react
now open your command prompt now you can
type in the path
for the folder that you just created so
say
cd users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command
npm install hyphen g
create react app okay so this command
installs all the necessary react.js
modules
now to check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in
create react app
version so you can see the version here
now let's continue and develop your
react application
type in the command create react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say
my app now this should take a couple of
minutes
okay once you've successfully created an
application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands
so let's do that save cd my
app and npm start this should typically
start
your application and here we go all
right
you can also open your application in
the text editor that you've downloaded
so let's go ahead and open vs code
vs code file open folder go to your
desktop or the
drive that you've saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see
all your modules have been imported you
can click on app.js
and start editing in today's video we'll
be learning all about the most
basic infrastructure of react.js called
components
without delay let's begin and look at
what's in store for us
so we'll be touching on topics like what
are components
types of components nesting components
higher order in pure components
and a brief description about component
life cycle all right to begin with
what exactly are components components
are the building blocks of a react
application
wherein each component represents a part
of the user interface now to make it
more understandable
consider the facebook home page the
entire ui can be broken down into
several elements
say we have the credentials component
the sign up component
the image component and the logo
component notice that
each component adds something to how the
home page looks
all right reusability is one of the
salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across
the application and this improves the
development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components
in its minimal form a component must
define a render method that specifies
how
exactly the application looks and feels
a component can also receive
properties from its parent components
also you'll get a better understanding
of all of these when we start working
hands-on so don't worry
so moving on let's look at the different
types of components
first we have the stateless functional
components and then we have the stateful
class components
now functional components are typical
javascript functions that return html
now they can be contained in a dot js
or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or a dot jsx file
okay then let's go ahead and build our
first react application
using components alright so i've opened
my text editor that is vs code to build
my application
also i suggest you watch the react
installation on windows video to help
you get started the video briefly
explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application
in my case i've opened a folder called
react component tutorial
and here in my source folder i have
app.js
now app.js is the main component that
gets rendered to the dom
let me show you that here in index.js
you pass
app.js which is a component that gets
rendered to the react dom
so app.js consists of several other
components that can be nested
so as you can see app.js is a functional
component
and before moving on let me get rid of
all the unnecessary code
so let me delete all of this
and return an h1 tag that says hello
welcome to sibling let me save it
and if you look at the browser you'll
have hello welcome to simply learn
now let's go ahead and display another
message say
h1 this video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser
it gives you an error so jsx uses a
conventional rule
which states that all html tags have to
be enclosed within a div
tag so for example i say div
and i enclose it so let me save and
check my browser again
here you go so multiple html tags have
to be enclosed within the div
tag moving on let's create a first
functional component
to do that i'll first create a folder in
my source folder
say components within that i'll create a
file
say functional component dot js
all right so the first thing we have to
do is import react so i say
import react from yeah
the general syntax for a functional
component involves
the keyword function and say
functional component now
you say return an h1 tag or i've already
used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you
how these components are exported and
imported let me show you the general
syntax for a class component
so i create another file say class
component
dot js i again import react
from react the general notation is using
the class keyword
followed by the name of the class
extending from the base class the
act.component
so going ahead i say class class
component extends react dot
component now the key feature of a class
component is the usage of a render
method
so i say render within braces i say
return
a paragraph tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on
let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js
components can be nested into the main
component using import and export
keywords
so as the name suggests export feature
is used to export a particular file or a
module and
import is used to import a particular
file or module into the current existing
module so we have two different types of
exports you have default export
and just export or named export so a
default export is used to export
just one object be it a function a class
a variable from the file and there can
only be one default export per file
and when you're importing it you can
specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our
editor and then functional component and
here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js
i say import name of the functional
component that is functional com
from and i pass the path this components
slash functional component also let me
get rid of these
unnecessary files here now let's define
functional component in our app.js
component
so here i say functional com let's
compile it
and check our browser here it says this
is a functional component
moving on to my class component it's the
same syntax here as well
i say export default name of my
component and in my app.js i import it
import class comp from the path
and again i'll have to define it in my
return method
i save so let me compile it and check my
browser
it says this is the class component one
unique feature
of default export is that i can rename
the file while i'm importing it so for
example
i can rename it as say fc
and while i'm defining it i'll have to
make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again
and when i check it it says this is the
functional component
there's literally no difference the next
type of export is the named export or
just export so a named export can be
used to export multiple objects be it
functions class etc from a file now
there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that
while you're importing it cannot be
renamed so let me show you how this
works
okay so let's create another class in
our class component
so i'll just copy paste this let me give
it another name say class com1
and the message that i want to display
is hey i'm another class
all right so when i'm exporting it i
don't want default
so let me take it off and say export
here all right
in my app.js while importing it i want
to import both the classes
so i'll include them within curly braces
here i say class com
comma class comp 1 and then again i
define it here
class comp 1. let's compile it and run
it
and here we go here you can see hey i'm
another class
so we've successfully exported both the
classes from the class component and
imported it back in our app.js component
one advantage of using named export is
the fact that i can choose to import the
classes that i want to
now say for example i do not want to
import class component here
so let me take it off and here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class that
was defined earlier is not imported here
all right so next up we have higher
order and pure competence
now i won't get into the nitty-gritties
of it because they're advanced topics
but to give you a brief
insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component
the whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works
let's go back to our code editor let's
create a component
in our components folder let's call the
component
click dot js all right so here
we define a class i use the snippet rce
here we go we get the entire format
using the small snippet
rce and here i'm going to make use of a
button
now see i use the tag button and i'll
say
clicked one time every time the user
clicks on the button
the value gets incremented so for this
i'm going to use a variable say count
and i'm going to use the concept of
states so let's go ahead and define our
variable count
and initialize it to zero so for that
i'm going to use another snippet
called r const and here this dot state
equals my variable count initializing it
to
zero so let's define the count variable
in a render method
so i say const count equals
this dot state so every time we
click on the button the count value has
to get incremented
right so we make use of an event called
on
click equals this dot
update click now update click is going
to be another method that we have to
define now
so every time the button gets clicked
this method is called
so let's go ahead and define the
function so it is
update click equals it's going to be an
arrow function
and i say this dot set
state is nothing but count this
dot state dot count plus one
okay and here we say count times
all right so once this is done let's
import our component
in app.js so here again
i say import click from
components click and let's define it
here
so let's check our browser every time we
click on the button
the value gets incremented all right so
let's go ahead and create another
component say counter.js where in every
time the user
hovers the mouse on the button the count
value increases
so let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet
rce to create a class component
and here in my div tag i define a button
and say incremented to for now i
say x so now let's go ahead and add the
event
say button on mouse
enter i'm going to call the method
this dot increment count
okay so once you're done with that let's
go ahead and define the increment count
method
i'm going to copy the same code that
i've mentioned in my click.js
so i say copy this all right so one
change is that i
change the name of the method and call
it
increment count again let's define the
count in our render method
so i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change
x to now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js
so i say import counter from
components and counter and let's define
it here
all right let's save it and let's run
the code okay so as you can see
you see another button here incremented
to zero and every time
i move my cursor on the button it
increments
mind you i'm not clicking i'm just
hovering my mouse
okay to learn how higher order
components work we'll have to pass
counter.js and click.js as parameters to
give birth to an entire new component so
for that let's go ahead and create
another component
for our hoc let's call it higher
order dot js okay so i say import
react from react after that i say
const updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again
and within curly braces i define my
class
that is class say new component extends
react dot component inside let's
define a render method that returns
the original component with a
modification
that is i want to type the user
i want to append the user before the
actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return
new component and let's export this
say export default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js
and pass these components as parameters
so let's do that
let's go to our counter.js and here i
say
import updated component
from dot slash higher order component
and here while exporting i say updated
comp and pass this as my parameter let's
do the same to click.js
here i import data.com
from higher order component and here i
pass this as a parameter
now here in a higher order component
we've defined a property
name and initialized it to the user so
we'll have to include this
in our other components that's counter
and click so let's do that
and here right before incremented 2 i
say this dot props dot
name let me save it let me do the same
thing here
and say this dot props
dot name so if you go back to our
browser here you can see it says the
user clicked zero times and the user
incremented to zero
okay so this basically shows how react
implements reusability of components
moving on
our next topic is pure components now
another way to create
class component is by extending pure
component from react a pure component
avoids unnecessary re-renders now how
does it do it it does not
implement the should component update
method now you learn about this method a
little later in the video now this
method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom
but a pure component on the other hand
ensures a shallow comparison
of states and props and checks if a
re-render is actually necessary only
then does it render to the dom
a react component can be considered pure
if it renders the same output for the
same state and props
so let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create
two component classes one for a regular
component and the other for a pure
component now using this example i'll
show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create
a purecomponent.js file i say
pureform.js
so here i'm going to use a snippet rpce
that is going to create
a pure component class let me get rid of
this export
and here in my div tag i'll display the
text
say i'm the pure component all right
now let's go ahead and create a regular
component let me call it
regularcomponent.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce
and the message that i want to display
is i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two
so let me create one here i'll call it
parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component
and here i display the message i am the
parent component
to change the state of the component
we're going to make use of a constructor
so let's use the snippet our const and
here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn
now we make use of the component did
mount lifecycle method
to set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn
about it a little later in the video so
moving ahead i'm going to make use of
the
method and say component did mount
and here i say set interval the first
argument
is going to be an arrow function and the
second will be the time interval
and i'm going to be setting it to 3
seconds now within the arrow function
i'll make use of the set state function
to set the state of my property however
i do not
change the name i keep it simply done
itself
moving on let's import pure component
and the regular component into a parent
component
and then pass name as a property so to
do that
first import pure comp from
pure component and then i say import
regular com from regular form.js
and here let's say regular comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this dot state dot name
now let's include the property name in
both our regular and pure components
so to do that let's just say this dot
drop dot name and here i again
say this dot prop dot name and finally
let's import parent component into our
app.js component
so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com so now if you look at the
browser
we have i'm the parent i'm regular
component simply learn and i'm the pure
component simply done we've got the
result as expected
now to check if the pure component is
actually read entering or not
let's include simple console.log
statements so here
i say clg snippet and here i say
pure component render
and in my regular component i do the
same thing i say
console.log regular component
render now let's do the same in our
parent component as well
here i say parent component
render all right so let's go back to our
browser and
inspect it in our console first the
parent component gets rendered
then the regular component and then the
pure component after that
for every three seconds only the parent
component and the regular component is
rendered
for the same state and prop the pure
component is not
re-rendered so in conclusion pure
components optimize react codes
and also improves performance so coming
to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
comprehend life cycle explains the
stages the component goes through the
entire life cycle of a component can be
divided into three parts
we have mounting updation and unmounting
so the first thing that gets
invoked in the life cycle is component
will mount
it is invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs
then we have the rendering method now
once a component is inserted into the
dom
component did mount gets invoked coming
to the next phase we have updation
when a complaint receives props
component will receive props
gets invoked set state is called when
the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component
state should trigger a re-render or not
to do that
should component update method is called
component will
update is invoked right before
re-rendering after re-rendering
component did update is called that
makes updates to the dom
and the last phase is unmounted
component will unmount method does all
the necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and cycles
in our previous video we learned about
react.js components in detail
and now moving ahead let's learn about
another striking feature of react.js
called props props short for properties
allow the user to pass
arguments or data to components a
pairing component can pass
additional information to its children
using props
properties help make components more
dynamic
props are passed to components in the
way similar to that of html track
attributes
now we'll look at this a little later in
the video props in a component
are read only and cannot be changed one
thing to remember is that props
are sent by the parent to the children
components hence the children components
cannot make any changes to these props
now that we've learnt about props in
brief let's go ahead and create our
application using props
if you're new to this tutorial i suggest
you go to the react installation and
react components video
on our channel so back in my code editor
that is vs code i've opened a folder
called
react props and now i'm going to create
a component
a class component and i'll call it class
props dot js so let's create the class
component
i give rce the snippet
and here i display a message saying an
h1 tag basically
[Music]
all right now let me get rid of export
here
and import it in my app.js main
component
here i say import
class props all right now we define the
class component in our render method
let's say
all right now if we go back to the
browser you see hello learners welcome
to simply learn
now let's say we want to individually
welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props
now let's see how to do that now we pass
the name
as a property from the main component
that is app.js
to the child component and render this
onto the browser
so let's do that so here while i'm
defining my child component
i say name
i save it and here in my child component
instead of learners i say i use the
keyword this
dot props dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner one
welcome to simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner 2 and learner
3
so i again say class props name
equals learner 2.
all right so if we save and look at the
browser
we'll have all the three learners
displayed on the browser
we can also pass multiple props to the
child component
now say for example we want to welcome
the student from a particular place
so we say welcome learner1 from place x
so i can here define another property
say
place and say
place similarly i can do it
for the rest too say place y
now let's go back to our classprops.js
component
and here say hello learner1
from this dot props
dot place let me save it
and if you look at the browser now we
have hello learner1 from place x
place y and place z we can also display
whatever we want between the opening and
closing tags when invoking a component
now this is facilitated using props dot
children reserved keyword now let me
explain to you
how it's done with an example here let's
split the self and closing tag
into an opening and a closing tag and in
between them
let me display a message within the
paragraph tag let me say
and in my child component after my h1
tag let me use a paragraph tag
and here let's use the reserved keyword
this dot props top children
so let's save it and now if you look at
the browser
you can here see the message displayed
child component
so prop stop children can be used when
components do not know about their
children ahead of time
this is commonly seen in components like
sidebar and dialog
that represent generic boxes so let's go
ahead and
create a button tag and check again so
here i'll split it and add
a button tag and say click
and let's check our browser here we go
we get the output as expected all right
we saw the usage of props
for class components similarly we can
use it for functional components
so let's go ahead and create a
functional component let me call it
i say import react from
react and then i say function
function props and here i return
an h3 tag
[Music]
i'll say this is functional component
and i'll return another hc tag saying
hello learner so let me save this
and let's export it export
default function
props and import it
in our app.js again import
function prop from
function prop and here
in our render method let's define it
let me call function prop
name let me give learner 4
and place
place say a let me
close it and back in a functional
component
instead of learner i say
props dot name let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says props is not defined
so let's go back to our code editor and
pass props here
to our functional component also let me
define
hello props dot name
from props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go
we get the output as expected so let's
begin and learn what exactly is a state
in react
typically a state is an object that
stores the values
of properties belonging to a component
now these values can change over a
period of time either via user
interactions
or network changes and the state helps
facilitate this functionality
every time the state changes react
re-renders the component to the browser
the state is initialized in the
constructor a state can also store
multiple properties
a method called set state is used to
update the value of the state
object now this function performs a
shallow merge on the new and the
previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learnt about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component
they have significant differences so
let's go ahead and draw a comparison
between the two
firstly props in a component are used to
pass data and event handlers to its
children
while state on the other hand is used to
store the data that has to be rendered
on the web page
props are immutable once set by the
parent they cannot be changed
state holds volatile data and can be
changed over time
props can be used in functional and
class components while state is
restricted to class components
props are set by the parent component
while a state is generally updated by
event handlers
now that we've learnt all about state
let's go ahead and build an application
to see the working of state
alright so in my code editor that is vs
code i've created my application say
state
and here in my source folder i have my
app.js file
now here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary
code that i'm not going to be using also
i suggest you go through the react
installation on windows video to
help you get started with creating your
first application
so let's create our class component say
class
app extends react dot
component inside i have a render method
that returns an html tag let's display a
message
welcome let's follow the jsx conventions
and enclose all the html tags within the
div tag
so i say div class name equals
app we also have to import the app.css
file
import app dot css
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome
now let's beautify our code to do that
let's add some styling
so here in my app.js class component i
say styles
equals and i say font
style and i set it to say bold
and i say color say
teal and here in my h1 tag i say
style equals this dot
styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold
now let's go ahead and create a class
component to understand
state so first i create a folder and i
call it
components and inside this folder i
create
a class component and i call it new comp
dot js and i use the snippet rce
to create the class component to give
you an insight into what we're doing
today
we'll display a message asking the user
to subscribe to simply learn
once the user clicks on the subscribe
button we instruct them to click on the
bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we are
going to make use of state
and as mentioned earlier we initialize
the state object in a constructor
so let's use the snippet r const to
create a constructor
now in the state object we initialize a
property
let's call it message and we display a
message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this dot state dot
message let's save it and now let's
import it in our app.js component
so i'll get rid of export here and here
i say
import new comp from components and new
comp
and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says
subscribe to simply learn all right
again to make our code look more
presentable let's add in styles
so i'll just copy the same styles that
i've added here
and i'll paste them here and instead of
bold i make it italic
and i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag i define
style and initialize it to this dot
styles
so let me save it and now if you look at
the browser it's
in italic and it's in purple okay so
moving ahead
let's create a button that reads
subscribe and once the user clicks on it
the button should read subscribed
and the message displayed above should
instruct the user to click on the bell
icon
to do that let's first create a button
the message that i want the button to
read is subscribe
however this message gets changed once
the user clicks on the button
so instead of explicitly mentioning
subscribe here
i create a prop i say sub
and i say subscribe here and back in my
render method
i say this dot state dot
sub so let's save it and if you look at
the browser now
you have a button which displays a
message subscribe now once the user
clicks on the button the message
displayed
should change to click on the bell icon
to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call
another method and let's call the method
button change okay so this method should
update the state
and change the message and sub values to
do that
we make use of a set state method now a
state can be updated in response to
event handlers
server responses or prop changes now all
the updation can be done using the set
state method now this is the general
syntax used by the method
we'll have a look at this further in the
demo now the set state method
conventionally enqueues all the updates
made to the component state
and instructs react to re-render the
component and its children with the
updated state
now let's go back to our code editor and
look at the working of this method
now here i defined the arrow function
button change
if you are not familiar with arrow
functions i suggest you read up on them
and this is the general syntax and here
i say
this dot set state and inside
i change my message to hit
the bell icon to never miss
an update and my sub value changes to
subscribed let's save this and now if
you look at the browser
when we click on the subscribe button
the message changes to hit the bell icon
to never miss an update
so moving ahead let's use a bell icon so
that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen
so for that i have two images i have
bell a and bell b
so i drag and drop both the images in my
components
folder all right now let's import these
images into our new com.js file
here i say import bell a
from bell a dot png
and again i say import bell b
from bell b dot png all right let me
save it
to display the image on the screen we
make use of the image tag
now this tag has two attributes one is
the source attribute that specifies the
url
and the other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image
so here in my component i say i make use
of a paragraph tag
that will help display the image in the
next line
and then i use the image tag now since
my image changes once it's clicked
i have to define a property and pass the
event handler click
that will update the image so here
before
specifying the source let's go back to
our state
and define another property
that is image url and let's set it to
bell a since that is the image that i
want to display first
let me save it and here in my image tag
i say source
equals this dot state
dot image url and then we have the alt
tag
and i do not want to display any message
so i leave it as it is
now let's save it and if you look at the
browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell
so back in my vs code i define style
with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this
and now if you look at the browser we
have a smaller icon
so once the user clicks on this image
the emit changes
and the message displayed here gets
updated to do that we'll have to define
an event
so let's go back to our vs code and here
in my image tag
let's say on click i define a method say
this
dot image change and now
we define this method here i see
image change i make use of an arrow
function again
and again i use the set state method i
update the image
so i say image url is now set to bell
b and the message is updated
to thank you happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser
we see the image and once clicked on it
the image gets updated
and the message changes so finally let
me refresh the browser once and show the
full execution
let me refresh following the
instructions let's click
on the subscribe button and now it says
hit the bell icon
and once i do that the image updates and
the message
changes so let's start with
creating a simple demo on react.js
and we are going to create a simple
application
that will connect to an online music
streaming service called spotify
and we will call our application music
app so
let's get started the first step is to
first get the node.js
platform and server installed to do that
let me go to google
and let's just type node.js and here is
the website nodejs.org there are two
versions available
the lts which is the stable version and
the current
we'll prefer the stable so we'll click
on that and
you can see we have an option which is
called save file
the moment this file is saved to the
disk we just need to double click on it
and keep clicking on the next button to
get it installed
on our system and we also have a
documentation
available here so which explains most of
the features
of the node platform and there are
binaries available for different os's
mac
windows etc so you can select the right
witness 32-bit 64-bit and
the right os and then go ahead and
download the specific uh version that
suits
your platform and you can see here
that there are different there are also
help files available that will allow you
to
go through the installation documents
for node.js installation on linux
etc so to start with uh i'm opening up
the command prompt
and here is where we're going to call
the node package manager
using the node package manager which is
pre-installed with your standard node.js
installation we will initialize our
react application
so we would say react dash app and
we want to now go and create an
application called
music app in this folder so as a
prerequisite for the demo
all we need to do is install node.js
from node.js.org the official website
just download it
and install it and that's when you open
the command prompt you fire
npm which stands for node package
manager init for initialize
react dash app is a standard keyword to
initialize and create
a skeletal structure of the react.js
application and the name of the app
is music app so we'll hit enter we'll
give this
some time and you can see it's started
downloading the core
react.js libraries and it is attempting
to create
our application so it's installing all
the prerequisite packages
and scripts that are required initialize
and create
a new react.js application called music
app
now once this application is created all
we would require
is an online editor so you could use an
offline or an on-premise editor as well
so any editor of your choice
it could be atom or sublime text or
webstorm
and for this demo we are going to use
visual studio code which is a free
editor
available by microsoft and you can just
google for visual studio code
again this is not visual studio
professional edition etc that we use for
building our c-sharp or mvc based
applications this is a lightweight
editor for building javascript based
footstep
full applications so so while this
installs
let's go and take a look at uh visual
studio code so this is the visual studio
code
editor and this is the editor that we've
installed directly downloaded from
visualstudiocode.com and
installed it and all we need to do is
open up this
folder that would be created with all
the prerequisite files in it
we just say file open folder and we
would open that folder
within our visual studio code editor so
we'll give it a while
until that application gets generated
and once it's created
we will again implement the component
based design and architecture
and the data flow between the components
and we'd also look at connecting to a
live data source
which is a json set of characters that
we would consume which is a restful
service
the set of music tracks exposed as a
restful api
endpoint by spotify which is a premium
streaming service
we will connect to that and we will look
at accessing some of the music tracks on
that website
okay so we've got uh the application
created here
so let's minimize this and we'll open up
our editor or we've got to say is file
and open folder
and let me go to the react.js demo
folder so this is the music app
that got created and that's exactly what
we're going to open up here
so we'll navigate to that folder
it's called music app we'll select it
and
have it opened in our application so you
can see here we've got a node modules
folder this has all of the pre-installed
packages that
make up the react.js library we've got a
folder called
public which will have the index.html
file that's the root
file that will launch so this is the
single page
application that we typically create in
a react
you have a single page which on which
we're going to load multiple components
so that's the index.html and then we
could go and create
a folder structure currently if i open
the source folder
we can see a single app.js file and that
basically is
the file that has uh the source code in
javascript for a single component
which we are interested in adding on to
our page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding css file
and then we've got the a public folder
with
the index.html file which is going to be
the root html file that launches
when we run our application so let's
uh go right up here and let's add
a link to an additional file so i'm
going to link to another style sheet
okay so we'd say relationship is equal
to stylesheet
and the type is going to be text
and css and we will reference
a file called reset
dot css and this is a file that we
look at adding up later on it doesn't
exist at this point in time so
we will connect this and that's purely
for styling purposes
so that we can have all of our css
styles defined there
next thing i'll right click on the
public folder we'll create a new file
we'll name this file as reset dot
css so that's going to be the css file
that will have
all of the css styling that we're going
to apply
and i'm going to use a ready code
snippet
for the css code so let me just
uh okay so i'll all i'll do is i'll just
go and pick up
a ready css file that i can just go and
use
if you look here i have a set of uh css
files that are created that
we're just going to use within our
application
and and that will avoid us spending a
lot of time on the styling so that we
can focus on our core concepts
uh which is actually learning how
component based architecture works and
how do we set up components
and have data communication between them
in react so
uh here is a file called uh reset.css
let me just fire up notepad and i'll
just open up this file
copy up the text here and i'm going to
just paste it
within uh reset.css and if you look at
the code uh
very simple it's all about uh styling so
we've got
uh article aside etc all html5 tags set
up as display blocks so they take up the
entire bit of the page
we've got some padding margin and font
size etc defined
we've removed list styling for the
unordered and ordered lists
specifying the line height for the body
tag so basically uh
just styling up tables and so nothing
nothing to do with react here it's just
about simple
uh css that we've added up uh and now we
need to actually go in and dive into
create creation of the components that
we need
so let's right click on the source
folder so i'll select the source folder
we'll right click there
and that's where we're going to create a
new folder which is called
components okay so this is the
components folder now that's going to
hold
all of the components within it within
the components folder let me create
another new folder and i'm going to call
it app and this is exactly how
we are expected to structure all of the
code that we have
now i already have a css and app.js
which are the root components that were
added by default and all i'm going to do
is i'm going to move them within this
folder called app
okay so there's a proper segregation of
responsibility
and all of the code that deals with a
particular component
is all added into respective folders and
this really improves the maintainability
of the application
uh going forward now we need some images
and i'm just going to make use of some
set of images that i've downloaded from
the web
and here are the set of images that i
have
so i'm just going to copy all of them
and we'll come to
our music app and we'll go into the
components and app folder and that's
where we're going to add all of the
files and you've seen
all of those image files getting added
so these are just icons and images we're
going to use for our music tracks
inside our application now let's move to
the app.css file
and this is where we've actually got
so the app.css file is the file that's
going to style up
the all of the style rules that we've
added
into the root app component and this is
what we'll have to
revamp so i'll just get rid of this code
and
we'll probably add something for the
body tag the html tag
and the root element let me say hash
root
and let's set the height to 100
coming to all of the html across the
page
we'll give it a font size of 10 pixels
and the h1 elements
let me give it a padding of 0.77
and 0 let's set a background
color give it a background color and
just select
some random color here that can be
applied then
we'll set up the text alignment which is
going to be
the center of the page we'll set up the
font family
the font family is and this is part of
sans serif what else do we add let's add
up the font size
1.88 and also the color
so again uh these are standard uh html
and css
elements so uh nothing really that has
to be done
that is specific to react here so again
we are bringing in the highlight class
so there is
a class called highlight that we will
create later in the
html view of this component and we will
set this to a red rgb component
so combination of 46 113
and 238 okay so that's uh
pretty much done let's move on
and also add up for the anchor tag
let's add up some text decoration and
set it to none
so that the anchor tags don't come up
with those underlines
and of course we'll provide a color of
hash okay so a white color there
now coming to the h2 element for the h2
element
let's have font family and again
i'm going to use so i'm going to use
the font family that we defined here
bracket and we
change this to probably 1.55
okay now coming to the app tag uh let me
just
save this and create a copy of it uh
there was some content
that i did delete and
i can simply go and make use of it so
i've just
undone all of the deletion so this is
uh something that i can't uh if i can
use something i can just probably
use it from the tag below so let me
start with the height here
and let's say the height of the header
is 100 of the app sorry not header
padding 0 17
10 17 the background
and i'm going to change that to
background url
so the background url or let's say the
background
image will have a url property
okay and that url is going to be
dot slash pg1.jpg so that's the image
that we've added
some in the previous step let's also
add background size
so we'll add background size and
set it to cover i'll also need
a background position to center
let's have background repeat which is
set to
no repeat so that we don't have the
image in a grid
format uh and then i would need this
bit of it let's take up the font family
we'll maintain the same font family
let's use font weight the font weight
is going to be 500 and the color is
going to be
hash so that's a white color then we
come to
dot app.playlist so that's going to be
another class that we are going to use
dot but
app dash playlist is what we we're going
to name it
and let me say that the display
should be flex flexible display
and we will justify the content to leave
spaces
in between all right so that uh finishes
that bit and
now uh let's write up a media query
for the responsiveness of this page so
this is media for only screen
and max width is going to be one zero
two zero pixels
okay and the class name that we'll
provide later
is obviously app playlist so for this
screen
size we would align all the items
to the center and we change the flex
direction
okay so we seem to be good with the css
for the app as of now and that's the
app.css
that we created let me save everything
okay let's check for any kind of
uh additional so all three of errors
no errors now things are good in the app
css and it's time to move to the next
step
of building this application uh now
we'll have to go
and add up the code for
the app.js file so let's dive into the
app.js file
and this is where we will actually need
to go
and add all of the code that is required
for the app component so all the code
that's relevant to
the app component we are going to add up
inside this
specific component itself which is going
to be obviously the
app.js file so we have skeletal code
which is import
importing the react library and let me
get rid of the
basic sample logo we'll have app.css
that's getting imported here
besides that lot of other files that
we'll have to get in so
let me import playlist and this is these
are the components that we'll create
as we go forward and we're going to get
this
from the playlist folder and the
component
the file is going to be called playlist
so we'll add that
then we'll have to go and also import
search bar
so what we're basically doing is we're
going to split this app into different
components there's going to be one
component that manages uh the playlist
of all the tracks uh one component will
act as the search bar so that's the
search bar
component that we're going to add so
searching for tracks will be managed by
this we'll have another component that
we'll create
that will get imported into the root app
component which is a
search results so this is going to
display the record set
with the set of results as an outcome of
the search criteria
so search results slash search
results and finally we'll go and import
spotify that's the spotify service from
so we'll create a utility folder which
will hold
the code that connects us to spotify so
that's what we are adding up next so all
of the imports are done one component
that manages
the search bar so that search bar search
results let me correct the spellings
there that search results that spotify
and playlist so that's done now let's
move on to
the class that we're going to create
here so let's create
a class app that goes and extends
dot component so that's going to be a
react.js component
so that's a constructor we discussed
about props
or properties and state management and
that's what we are implementing
we are using the super keyword as a best
practice
so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor and
also we pass the values up the chain to
the
superclass which is the root component
class now we're going to initialize
a variable called state that's going to
manage the state
and we are interested in tracking our
search results so we'll have multiple
results so we'll store that as an array
the playlist
would have different names so we'll just
call
ours new playlist that's the default
name
and we will also store a list of
tracks which is going to be playlist
tracks so playlist tracks is going to be
a list of tracks
and let's close this block okay and this
two
is going to be initialized within the
constructor so we'll add it here
and now we need to do the binding we
discussed uh
data binding so let's look at creating a
search
variable which will hold this dot
search dot bind and bind to the context
of
this very class so we are passing this
pointer then
we'll create another variable called add
track which to this dot add track dot
bind and all this functionality is what
we're going to add going forward so
right now
we're just setting up the bindings then
we'll have
capability to remove a track so we'll
say remove
track so remove track equal to this
dot remove track dot bind
and let's fix that
so and all of these two is going to be
initialized as part of the
constructor so that's where we're going
to add it then we'll need to update
update the playlist name
so we need functionality that will help
us to update
the name of the playlist so
functionality that helps us to update
the playlist name so this dot update
playlist
name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind
and this is the pointer that we'll pass
i need to save the playlist so this dot
save playlist equal to this
dot save playlist dot find
and pass this and then i would also need
to
remove the track that has been searched
for from the playlist
so remove track search go to this
dot okay remove track search and
dot find and finally one last function
that
executes all of these which probably
will bind
to bind to this context so all the
declarations
are done in the constructor now we need
to provide
the definitions for all the methods that
we actually have
added here so let me select this tab
inside and let's start
with the search function so we define
the search first
it takes some variable value that it
searches on and then
i'm going to say spotify dot
search i'm going to search for term dot
then and that's an observable so
the moment it the search returns a value
it's going to call this
uh callback function and that's when we
want to set
the state and we're going to set the
state
for search results to whatever is passed
by the system so the search results are
going to be returned
as a callback and that's what we store
as an updated state
now coming to the add track method so
let's scroll up
and we'll say add track and this will
take the track to be added
let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this
dot the current state of all the tracks
that are there
in the playlist now if track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to
find which means that the track is
already there in the playlist
then we would not want to add it if it's
not there
in the playlist that's when we would
want to go
and it the triple equal to is an
equality operator that will check for
both
a watch value match and a match on the
data type as well
okay so if the track is uh already saved
to nothing if the track is not safe just
track the
track id because that is the track that
will uh
have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks
we'll use the javascript method called
push and we will push the current track
into this tracks array and then update
the state
so we want to set the state of the
playlist
tracks and this is how uh your state
management that we discussed
in detail is actually being practically
implemented here
okay so the track has been added now
let's talk about the remove track
so that's the remove track function and
that's
the track that we want to remove so
let's
let tracks equal to this dot state
dot playlist tracks those the set of
current tracks that we have
and let track search another temporary
variable
equal to this dot the current state of
the search results
then let's take the tracks array equal
to
track start filter so filter is of
javascript function that will again
allow you to remove a certain value
create a temporary variable called
current
track use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id
is not equal to the track
dot id which means this particular track
is not there in the list okay so
you need to remove that and again i have
a method called as unshift which will
actually
get rid of the track in the array and
then we've got to
so we'll search whether that track is
existing
in the tracks array if it is then we
simply want to remove it if not we do
nothing
so we set the state we need to update
the state of the playlist because the
track has been removed
so the playlist tracks will have to be
updated with this
tracks array okay then we go for remove
track search that's the next method that
also will take
a track as a parameter okay here we are
going to say
let tracks which is another temporary
variable we
give it this current state of search
results
and then we are going to say tracks
equal to tracks dot
filter current track current track
dot id not be equal to the track
dot id and then this is where we would
want to say
this dot set state
and we'll pick up search results and
let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh
set of tracks after making the change
let's
remove this and correct it okay so
that's fine
so the remove track uh is now the remove
track and the remove track search is now
in place let's add the do these
functions
which actually again takes track as a
parameter
and here we'll say this dot add track
okay so it adds the track and then it
removes the track from the search
criteria so the search component which
is managing searching of the tracks that
will go and remove it from there after
adding the new track
so that's a combined operation we want
to
execute then i've got update playlist
name which will take the name of the
track to update and this
dot set state the playlist name
is what we need to update with the name
that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists
so here we let me create a constant
variable constants are variables whose
values will not
frequently change we'll take all the
track uris
dot state dot playlist
tracks will be dot map
create a temporary variable called track
track dot
uri so we actually want to go and uh now
save this on a spotify
so that's the reason we'll access
spotify's
safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name
comma track uris and if that is
successful we then go and do a callback
so that's the callback anonymous
function where we're going to say
this dot set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called
new playlist so that's the custom name
that i want to provide
and the playlist tracks define
that this closes here okay so that's for
the update on
spotify now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript
and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your
html view and synchronize and bind the
data
together so it helps from a
maintainability perspective
so even though everything is in the same
file it's well
classified and differentiated into
different code blocks
so we'll add the anchor tag and we'll
say href
is http localhost so that's the default
server port on which this application
will run
okay and we want to give it a custom url
name of music or file
so the h1 terminates will then say div
class name equal to app within that
this is how we're going to inject a
search bar
that's going to be the search bar
component
injected here and on search so that's
the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search
we just call we bind to a method called
this dot search then we'll open up
another div
here we'll have class name equal to app
dash playlist and if you remember that's
exactly the css
class name that we refer to in the css
file we have
another component called search results
that we're going to inject here and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to
this dot state dot search results so
that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be
displayed with the data bound and if
somebody says add
if if i click on the add button the
search results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist
by calling binding to the 2ds function
and it will remove it from the
search results text box then we have
another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks will be
bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor
then we provided the function
definitions okay that's how
and this that we passed refers to the
context of the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things
we'll have to do is if somebody changes
the name of the track so on name change
is going to be another custom event
where we have to call this dot update
playlist
name and we also have remove
functionality so to remove a track
we would say equal to this dot remove
track on save equal to this dot save
playlist okay
so that's done and we close this so we
seem to be pretty much
on track the export app will make this
all of these functions accessible across
other components
it's very similar to the public access
specifiers etc that you provide
uh in other programming languages so
that's done
we've created our app component now
let's create
another folder under components and
we've got to define
all our various components here this
folder is
going to be for the search bar so we'll
name it search bar
we'll add two files within it the search
bar dot css okay and
another file that we'll need here is
search bar dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file
so we'll start with first styling search
bar we will say that the display should
be flex
flex direction should be column
we want all the items to be aligned at
the center
so that's align item center then we'll
add up padding
so padding top is going to be
6.94 rpm
and margin bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right
now let's add up for the search bar
so that's search bar we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be
287 pixels the padding
to be zero point eight eight
zero the border should be one pixel
solid white the border radius will give
a slight rounded edge uh to give a web
3.0 look and feel so we'll set up the
border radius
then we've got margin bottom
so we've got a pattern margin that we
want to add up
then we have color so let's add up the
color
c3f so that's the color black then let's
add
text alignment of center
and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up
let's add the search bar input
is going to be so if someone focuses so
focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box so
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
on input and if the input is focused so
that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search
button so on the search button the
cursor
will set it to pointer so that's the
cursor pointer
the width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and
0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly
uh well defined search button with a
nice little border
let's also add background color hash
1 db 954
that gives me color then i've got my
text alignment
let's set that to center then we've got
a font family let's set up the font
family to the same standard font
8t and it's a part of
the sans serif family then we'll set up
the font size to 0.833
rem correct this and finally
we will need transition so all of these
are
basic css properties so that will add a
slight
transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds so transition
background color we've provided what
else let me scroll up
let's also provide a border here so we
remove
in fact let's remove the border we we
would not want a border on the button
that would look
odd so i'll get rid of the border and
color we'll specify
as per our standard color that we've
been using okay so that's the color
we've specified and then i've got
font weight of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button
we will register for the over event so
if someone takes
their mouse over the button that's the
over the
event in that case uh if we hover around
the button we would want
the background color to change so it
will
appear to have a slight little glow
there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity
and the rgb combination so that
completes uh
the css file for the search bar and
we obviously now need to go and
get the code in for our search bar
component and that's exactly
what we are going to do next so let's
start with
setting up the code for the search file
first thing
let's go and import react from
react next thing we would want to do is
import the search bar dot
css file then we define a class
called search bar which extends
react dot component we define
our constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we'll just need one variable
here which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then
let's say this dot will define a
function called
handle term change which is going to be
equal to this dot handle handle term
change dot find so that's going to be
the first function
then a function that will do the
searching for us which
is this dot search so that's the search
function
and we'll have it bind to this then
we've got
this dot handle enter
so the moment we enter into that search
text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one
which is handle term change we'll pass
it a system defined keyword of
event this dot set state
and for the term we will use the event
keyword
we will get the value that is there
inside that text box the moment the
search term
the user is entered changes so the
search criteria changes we trap the
updated value
then in the search function we will
update
the local property props dot on
search okay so we'll access the on
search
and pass it the updated term
and then we got the handle enter
on which uh we're also going to pass the
system define
event keyword so if there's any data
flowing along with the event
we are interested in it in this case the
data is the key code that the user is
pressing and if it is 13 that indicates
uh
that's the ascii key code for the enter
button so if the enter is hit then the
user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where
we write our render method that's going
to render the html view
and we return the complete view here
so that's the view now that we want to
return let's say diff
class name equal to search bar then on
the input text box
we will use placeholder equal to enter
song album or artist that you want to
search for on change on the on change
event
the moment the term changes we connect
that to
handle term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on
key up is where we would want to connect
to
this dot handle enter okay and this
is place bracket that i'll have to put
up here
so in the render function uh we're going
to return a value
i shouldn't forget to export the search
bar okay so that's uh
what i want to export so we've exported
that okay so at the end of this uh
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close the div
tag
we've added an input and here is where
i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment
the end user clicks on the button we're
going to connect it to
this dot search and we
close the button tag within the button
tag
search so that completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's
run through all of what we've written we
started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor
passing props to the super class
constructor
we created state we set it to
a value of term and null so the state
currently we defined as term then we
said handle term changes search and
handle enter should be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render
render we said is going to return to us
the html
that we've specified okay we dumped all
the
html that we want this component to
return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that or two events that we
connected to
where we called handle term change and
handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event
and connected it to this dot search so
all the three functions
uh that we are actually written
uh so two things we have completed now
uh in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with
the playlist and adding applications etc
adding tracks delete removing tracks
then we've created the search bar
okay so we saw that the search bar also
we have specified a set of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care
to structure every component separately
so the search component
is doing something completely different
which is managing
the search bar we have the core the root
app component
in which we have imported all of the
other set of javascript classes
that we are creating and that's how the
entire
application is now structured so
and that's the core concept when you're
working with
react where you would actually have
every separate
block of code or every separate
functionality
handled in a different component
altogether
so we've completed the search bar
component as well
so two components done and two
components
good to go so we've got to start up on
the next set of components that we will
need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder
a new file called track.css
and track.js
so that's going to manage the tracks for
us
so let's start with dot track
we would say display is flex
align items center border
bottom one pixel solid rgba
256 256
256 0.8 that's the opacity
then let's come to track action
so we'll use all of these classes uh
when we write up the html view
we'll add a padding here of 0.5 we'll
set up a font
size of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s border of 0 pixel
and a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 hash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in
track another class track action and
if we hover over this class we want
the gb values change to 265
265 2 6 5 5 is the last parameter so
that's the hover
then we have track information so track
information
is the next class that we're dealing
with we'll add
the flex parameter first display
flex and then flex
direction is going to be column
let's have justify content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track
information let's have another track
information
and the h3 tags nested inside that
for all the h3 tags nested inside that
we'll need a margin
bottom of 0.22
rdm finally let's have
track information and paragraph tag
we'll have the font size of 0.83
rem and a font
weight of 300
and a color as well that we'll add so
let's add up
a color here rgba 2 6
256 256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's
uh that's in terms of the css and
let's move to the track and
we'll move into the javascript file
so let's move into so let me take what
we added in the search bar
i'll go to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change
to add track so add track
change this to add track this is
remove track change this to remove
track get rid of this and that's going
to be
the add track function and here we are
going to say
uh this dot props so we'll modify
this this dot props
dot on add this dot
props dot track and then we have
the remove track so that's going to be
the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot props dot on remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove
we'll add up another function called uh
render
action so this is going to be a function
uh that we are defining called render
action
and in this we'll just check if this dot
props dot is remove
if this dot props dot is
removable so in that case we would want
to return
so this is a view action method that we
are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as
track action that we've already written
the css for
and this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is what it's going to
map to let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag
okay so the closing button tag is what
we've added there
and the binding is what we have done
to this dot remove track and
we will terminate this here so now the
render action
uh let's also have the return
here and we just add up
the button and this is going to
add track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic
in nature so we have two buttons that
are going to be added
this button with a hyphen is going to
remove the track this button
with a plus sign is going to add the
track and
you can actually see how simply it was
done in a render action function so the
render action function
actually helped with checking
that if uh on the value of the props
and if the user uh depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track
or add a track from the existing
playlist
okay and then uh the class name here
is now going to be track the class name
for uh the enclosing div inside it so
let me
get rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div
here is going to be track
dash information within it we'll add
h3 we'll bind to this dot
props dot track dot name so the name of
the track
is going to get bound here then in the
paragraph
we will find to this dot props dot
track dot artist and
with some gap this dot props dot
track dot album so that's what uh
we've data bound to and then let me add
an iframe
an iframe allows us to uh very easily
inject some content into the page within
a small
embedded window the source parameter of
the frame
is going to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed
slash track and close this so that's the
spotify
stream that we are going to connect to
and this dot
props dot track dot id
so that's the track id the width
is going to be 300 the height parameter
this the height parameter is going to be
80 of the iframe and
the frame border is going to be zero
and the allow transparency
so that's the opacity we'll say true
let's add allow encrypted
media so if spotify has encrypted media
that also would be embedded here and we
can
also have the title set to preview
so that's uh with the iframe okay at the
bottom
is where we would want to so this could
be an empty element and
we can close it right around here so we
wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say
this dot render action so we call the
render action method
uh which will actually give us plus
minus button
to add and remove uh new element
okay and that's uh what we can actually
go and add up there
so let's check now whether
all that we've done is good to go fine
so everything looks good
uh in terms of the track component now
and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump
into the next component that we would
require
after the track component and that's
going to be
the track list so this is going to be a
list
component that will comprise of a list
of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this
track list and that's going to have
track list css and it's going to have
track list dot js so that's the
track tracklist component now which
we're going to go ahead and use and the
css
we don't need much so let's just say
track
list and we just provide a width
of 100 okay that's all we'll need
in the css so let me add this in the css
file
save this and come to the js file now
which is going to have the track list
code that we will
need to add up so here again i'm going
to say
import react from react
we'd also want to import track list
dot css and
we also want to go and get track because
this
component is going to be made up of a
collection of tracks
individual tracks so we want to get this
from
track slash track and we'll define class
track list which is going to go and
extend
react dot component we just need the
render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself
it simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks so this class name
is going to be track list
and we'll bind to this dot props dot
tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return the track
component which is going to bind to
individual track data the key is going
to be track
dot id so the key is going to be
track dot id and on add
on adding a new track we want to bind to
this dot properties dot and we already
have on add
defined so that's what we connect to we
add up
my base bracket here okay
and then we would also need
is removal equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove
will do this dot prop start
on remove so that's for the track
removal and so we've got our
track list oh yes we'll have to go
and also close the tip tag
correctly and also we
need to go and export so we'll have to
go and
export the track list
so we've got one more component done
which is track
lists and let's move on to the next
component
now so we've got app which is root we've
got the search bar that takes care of
entering the search criteria we've got
individual tracks that are searched and
returned and we've got a track list that
manages a set of
track records so the track is more
relevant to the playlist and then we've
got the search results also to manage
once we search for some set of tracks so
we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have search
results dot css and
it's going to have search results
dot js okay so we need a search results
dot css and js and here in the css file
we'll keep it
simple for the search results so we'll
say search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent
we set up the height of 950
pixels we'll say overflow
y is scroll we'll say
padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
95 23 23 0.7
and we will use the box model so we'll
provide
a shadow dropping shadow of zero four
pixels
pixels to pixels hash
and then uh let's add a scroll bar
so webkit and mozad are the constants
specific to mozilla and chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc
or properties that are specific to those
individual browsers
that's the reason we use those constants
and then
we'll also add a media query that
if it goes with a max with
one zero two zero pixels in that case
dot search results
width is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of 2
okay so we're going to add the hyphen
so it's hyphen webkit scroll bar zero
pixel width and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with
the css i need to get to the uh
js file now let's move to the search
results
js file and that's where we will now
have to go and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take pick this up from track
list
add it up here this would be search
results and we need the results will
return to us a list of tracks so we'll
have to get
uh track list this would be track
list and i'm just going to return
class name will also be search
results so that's the component and this
is going to export out search results so
it's accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create track list with
a set of tracks and we will bind it to
this
dot props dot search results
and on the on add we are going to bind
to
this dot props dot on add so we already
have that
so that uh basically completes search
results
and that leaves us with the last
component which is going to manage
the playlist for us so we'll add up a
new books we'll add up a new folder in
components
and that's going to be playlist and
within that
we will have a playlist dot css
and a playlist dot js
so that's our playlist component now
that we're going to work with and the
playlist component
is uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need to add up to
the playlist
and i'm just going to pick that up
from my code snippet so that's
my playlist and let me get all of that
css here so that's uh just a css for
the playlist nothing to do with react
again pure css
let me get uh into the js file and
that's where we will need to go and add
all of our component code
so again let me go to the track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it out here we'll make some
small changes
this is going to be playlist i need to
import the track list because the
playlist
is going to contain a list of tracks
this
is going to be playlist and
let me here this will be playlist
and we'll leave this for later okay let
me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here
and just one function that we will need
here
which is handle name change you know if
i need to change the name of the
playlist
so handle name change and that's exactly
the function that
we will need to write code for so that's
the event
and this dot props dot
on name change that's when we'll say
event dot target dot
value so we get the updated playlist
name
coming to the render we now need the
input
input is going to be on change
equal to this dot handle name
change the default value
we have already provided with a hard
coded value which is
new playlist so that's the default value
if not provided then we'll just pick up
the default value
then we've got track list so track list
is what i will add the tracks i'm going
to bind to
this dot props dot playlist
tracks so we're going to bind this to
playlist
tracks and here we will say
is removal equal to
true and on remove equal to we'll bind
that to this dot props
dot on remove finally we'll need a
button
we will use class name equal to
playlist dash save
that's what we've added in the css click
equal to this
dot props dot on save
and here we're going to say save to
spotify so that's with the playlist and
yes we need to go and export playlist
and not
track list now we'll need to uh
do a quick lookup in spotify
so let's go to this website called
developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in uh and create
an
id it takes us to our dashboard that's
where we can create
a sample application the name of the
application
will be musical file okay and
we'll say that we are building uh some
kind of desktop app for example
for which we want to connect this to and
we'll also need to provide
uh so we'll say next refresh the
dashboard
so it's uh asking me for a login so let
me
login once more so moment i log in
that's going to be
description and i'll say maybe this is
why i need it
i'll say no not commercial integration
agree with the terms and conditions
and we will say submit and that's the
application that has got created and now
i can say edit settings
and the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost
3000 that's the port on which we will
host our application
okay and we'll say save okay so that's
uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique so i'll just copy that up
let me come up to my application under
the source
folder i'm going to add a new folder
called
util and under that a new file
called spotify.js so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util
folder the first line of code is going
to
define a client id variable that equates
to
the client id that we will generate on
spotify
so this is going to be the spotify
generated client id which is a unique id
associated for the developer to connect
to the spotify api
and we will look at the source of that
as we go through the demo the
next variable that we'll create is the
redirect url
or let's call it redirect uri
and that will equate to localhost
colon 3000 which is the port and we'll
create
another variable called the access token
let's also create another constant
variable
called spotify and this will work like
a function expression so we'll equate it
to
a function called get access token and
we will say
if access token is true then
return the access token now let's
declare
a constant variable called access token
match
which will be equal to window dot
location dot href dot
match and we will say this is equal to
access token which will be equal to and
we will keep a rejects expression
to do a pattern match ampersand so that
we can actually get into the url and
extract
the token information from that and
hence
the pattern match is crucial here
another constant
variable called expires in
match equal to window dot
location dot href dot match
here we will read the expiry information
using another regex expression from the
url
ampersand asterisk so that's the second
constant variable we've created
now we will say if access token
match and expires in
match in that case the access token
should be equal to access token match
of one then we create a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from
the expires in match that's done
then we will say window.settimeout
and we are going to say access token
equal to comma expires in
multiplied by 1000 then we will say
window.history.push
state and we will say access token
we pass the second parameter as null the
last parameter as
slash and close this and we will return
access token else we will say const
access url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash authorize
client underscore id equal to
dollar client id ampersand response
type equal to token ampersand
scope equal to playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now
get generated so we will say modify
dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect
uri so we have constructed the url
now that will go out and get generated
in the browser and here we are going to
say window dot
location equal to access url
then we will add the search criteria
function which accepts
a term as a parameter to search on here
we will say
constant access token equal to
spotify dot get access token so we get a
reference to the same access token
return we call the fetch function and
we're going to pass
https api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash search question mark that's the
query string that we will add type equal
to track
and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization
where we will say that the pairer is
dollar access token dot then response
return response dot json dot
then so the return of this function once
it completes
we will then call the next function so
json response and then we will say
return response dot json
after that another then block so we'll
now say
json response and if
not json response dot
tracks in that case we will return
an empty array else we will return
jsonresponse dot tracks dot
items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as a variable with a
lambda expression
and we'll create a temporary json object
with id
and that's where we want to associate
track dot id
that was returned as the search result
the name
is going to be associated with track dot
name
the artist is going to be associated
with
track dot artists of zero dot
name the album is going to be track
dot album dot name and the uri
we will equate track dot uri so that
completes uh
this block will open the next and we
this will be the save playlist which
will take the name
and the track uris and here we will
check
if not name or not
track uris dot len in that case
we simply return out of the code and
then we declare
a constant variable called access token
which will be equal to spotify dot
get access token so we get a reference
to the access token we then declare
headers authorization bearer is going to
be
dollar access token and we'll create
a user id and now we will return
the fetch result where we will pass
https
api dot spotify dot com
slash v1 slash me so that's the url
comma headers will be the header
information then we call the then
function declare response as a variable
use the lambda expression and access
response dot
we use the then block to declare json
response
here we say user id equal to
jsonresponse.id and then we return
fetch https api dot
spotify.com slash v1
slash users slash dollar of
user id slash playlist so this is how
we've constructed the urls manually
here we will say assign headers to the
headers variable
we'll assign method as post so the data
is sent as part of the body
and not as part of the url and
as the body we will say json.stringify
to convert
this parameter name and then
we will generate a response variable
to dot json and
then we'll create json response
with the lambda operation we'll create a
constant
playlist id which is equal to
json response dot id we will
return fetch https
api.spotify.com
v1 users dollar
user id slash playlist
slash dollar again we are constructing
the url so playlist id will be replaced
here
then we will say tracks and close this
comma and here again we will say
headers would equate to the headers
variable be constant headers
and this goes here
okay everything fixed now so here we're
going to say
headers should equate to headers
and the method is going to be
post and the body
is going to be json dot stringify
uris track uris and we close this
we close this block we close this block
and we close this block so that
completes our code
of course one more thing we have to do
which is export this class out
so export default spotify
and that completes the code for the
spotify.js
which is part of our utils class
so let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is uh the client id
that we'll have to exactly match so i'll
copy this client id
and provide it here so that's the client
id uh
that we actually need and we could also
store it out here so that's the
client id and that's the redirect url
that we've also
defined there and we just create an
access token
if your access token is true we return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match
from uh the moment we try and connect
with this particular url and you can
look here that this is the access url
that we are trying to connect with okay
with the client id
and post fixed with the redirect url
right and then i've got a simple search
function which returns an observable
so we try to fetch data using the search
term that we provided
okay we try to fetch data using the
search term provided
if we are successful we get a response
of the data and
accordingly we'll iterate over the json
response and get a list of tracks out of
it and do a mapping of this json object
to the track id name
artist information album name etc and
here
uh just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save
function which will save this data to
spotify as well so i've got a save
playlist and i've got search so these
are the two functions which
will go and connect to the spotify
service uh by using
this client id and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning
a stream of json data and will then
allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we actually need
to
start up the application so i'll go to
the terminal and
rather let me go to view and bring out
the
terminal so this is the integrated
terminal that's there
in the tool and it just opens powershell
from which you can actually
fire your commands so i'm going to say
node package manager npm
start to actually start up this
application
so that's going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access
so i need to grant access to that port
3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app
now that you can actually see here so
this is the search bar that we actually
had
okay then we had the results we had the
playlist
now the results is going to consist of a
set of
tracks which are maintained by the track
list and then you can take individual
tracks with the plus and minus button
and add them
into the playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work
okay so as you can view here i'm just
going to search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us
uh a confirmation link the moment we
tried to connect
and execute our application uh that's
proof enough that it actually went
and connected to the service there
and tried to return a value to us so
this is what we did we just added an
artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons
getting added on the fly so that was the
render action
these are buttons that got added onto
this list of tracks
dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist
okay as in when i click here so i've
added a couple of tracks
if i go back to my dashboard of my
musical file
application and that i've created here
in the developers portal of spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank
so now i'm going to click on save to
spotify
okay and that clears the playlist so let
me come
here and now when i come out here
we saw that it actually got successfully
connected
out here now i'll have to log in to so
this was the development app that we
actually created on the developers
portal of spotify
now we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and
it says do you want to launch the web
player and all that so let me click on
that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist
that just got added right and there were
four songs
that i'd actually added to the playlist
and you can see here those four songs
have got added out here okay so i can go
here
and i can delete this playlist
and say i want to delete it okay so
there's no playlist now
i'll go back here i'll add two tracks
and i'll say save to spotify
so that's how you actually saw that the
new playlist you can see the new
playlist has come back here
okay and that's the playlist the
playlist has got generated again and
that's the new playlist
that got created and we deleted it
but it still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
uh that we successfully created with
this react app and the core concept of
the react app was breaking it down
into components which is the search
component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks
uh then we created the search results
which will generate a list of results
which further contains a track list and
this is the
embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here
and you can see that the iframes we
created allowed us to scroll
this uh with this embedded web page
inside the iframe container
so with that i hope we've been
successful with explaining the
concept of component based design and
architecture with react and how
important it is to create individual
components and the benefit of that
being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability
wherever you want the same feature to be
implemented on the page you can just
inject that same component and the same
implementation and the same features can
be reused so it promotes reusability it
promotes flexibility to change
it isolates your change request to
single components preventing the
massive effort of recompiling and
retesting the entire application as a
whole
in this session we'll be comparing the
three cutting edge ui development
technologies that is react.js
angular and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've
slowly progressed from server-side
applications to more distributed
applications where a part of the job is
done on the client side and a part on
the server side
and now we've transitioned to something
known as single page applications or sba
and all of these technologies that you
see on your screen right now are based
purely on javascript
as a result they're lightweight and
aren't dependent on any third-party
runtime tools
so let's compare the three technologies
and learn about the factors that make
them stand out
so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features
use cases and where they're applied
their performance how they handle data
the languages they use and the testing
mechanisms we learn about the dedicated
user community that backs these
technologies and finally we'll see the
growth curve
first we'll look into the salient
features now react is a front-end
javascript library
while angular and view are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably
they significantly different now library
is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them
frameworks on the other hand are like
models they have limited choices and
come with a blueprint of their own
and as a result the user doesn't have
much control so javascript being an
interpreted language where code is
executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment
and would definitely encounter a delay
now these are avoided and as a result
these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack
mainly because it's purely based on css
html javascript and jquery
single page applications as the name
suggests are built using single page
now the entire page is broken down into
several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component
handles the login the other one would
display icons and images and so on
all these bits or components are then
put together to form a single page
application
and moving on react was developed and
maintained by facebook
while angular was built by google and
vue was developed by evan unx
google employee now react represents the
view part of the mvc framework
and angular is a full-fledged mvc
framework in itself and view on the
other hand
is focused on view and the model layer
of the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework
now mvc framework is an object-oriented
design principle
that mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while vue deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application
and the controller drives the
functionality of the two any changes can
be easily factored and isolated and as a
result testing becomes a whole lot
easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective
in terms of react we have top websites
like facebook
instagram netflix that use react on the
other hand we have angular that is used
by nike
hbo forbes sony and vue is commonly used
by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature
now the moment you build an html view
and render it into the browser
this view to the user is basically just
html tags
however if you look at the internal
working the code is actually converted
into a balanced tree structure
this b3 algorithm is extremely fast so
when the user makes any changes to the
ui
the changes are reflected immediately
this is facilitated by the b3 algorithm
so as a result the performance is
improved
so how does react make use of this tool
it uses a virtual dom
dom is an api developed by w3c it stands
for document object model and defines
how the document is accessed and
manipulated
this dom parser converts the html code
into an inverse balance tree structure
so react uses the virtual dom while
angular uses the real dom
and vue uses the virtual dom again now
the virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages
and only changes the paths that need to
be updated angular on the other hand
updates the entire tree structure
regardless of any changes made or not
and view again only updates the ones
that have changed
since there is no time spent on making
unnecessary changes to the entire tree
react is extremely fast on the other
hand real dom updation is time consuming
risky and error-prone view also ensures
faster and bug free performance
now let's talk about data binding the
core reason why we would use single page
applications
now consider a scenario where you log
into an e-commerce website as the user
one then you should be able to see the
items in your shopping cart while user 2
would be seeing different items in their
shopping carts and so on so identifying
the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help
of data binding data binding is a
process that allows an internet user to
manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as
calculators tutorials games etc now
react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa
angular on the other hand uses a two-way
data binding while vue also uses a
similar two-way data binding
in react every time the model state
updates the view changes accordingly
however the reverse is not true in case
of angular any changes made to the view
are immediately reflected in the model
part of the architecture
view follows the same principle now this
hugely influences
the performance due to one-way data
binding react is modular and fast
improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance
and view on the other hand performs
according to the input type
moving on to scripting languages react
combines ui templates and javascript
logic resulting in a new language called
jsx
so react only requires the knowledge of
javascript angular uses templates again
in html you can also inject javascript
code into html using a clever
implementation in angular called
directives
so you can create a class and then
inject it into html
angular also does something better you
can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax
now vue again uses html based template
it uses html5
throughout for the ui and the
combination of javascript for business
logic
all view templates are valid html and
can be passed by html parsers
let's move on to testing now just as a
framework or an api that is developed by
facebook and is used to run tests on
react applications to ensure that they
are bug free now it is embedded
typically in every react library
and requires zero configuration now
angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases
this also ensures that the application
is error free
the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha
now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be
tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast
now let's talk about community support
since all these tools are
open source they have a large developer
community there are a few
popular github repositories for react
such as react.js 101
react.js.org and so on you can raise
queries
solve a few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react
here are a few repositories for angular
view also has a few popular repositories
you can commit
download third party plugins and also
explore these stacks even deeper
all of them surely have a very happening
community at the time of writing
there were about 1 million repositories
5 million comments
and 1 million issues with respect to
react here are the figures for angular
and here are the figures for view
according to npm stat
over the past two years there have been
approximately 360 million react js
downloads there have been around 38
million downloads for angular and around
63 million downloads for view
now let's look at the future scope
learning a new technology
always comes with questions like what's
in it for me what's its growth potential
how far will it take me in my career and
so on so let's go ahead and see the
growth rate of react angular and vue
according to google trends over the past
12 months react has been on a way
faster upward trajectory than angular
and vue which have considerably lost
their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two
with respect to popularity industry
adoption and community support
welcome to this session on how to
connect react.js with node.js
and in this session uh we are actually
going to look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on
react.js connectivity with node.js and
in this session
we are going to focus on how do we
connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform
so we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it
we would have the client application
that we will first create
as a react application we will then
create
an express gs application with node.js
and we will then try
to connect both of those applications
together
so express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application
very quickly on the node.js platform and
we'll use it
to create a custom api and then connect
that
endpoint to the react.js client
application
so let's dive into our demo and let's
start
with creating our client and node
express applications
and see how to set them up and then get
them connected to each other
let's start with our hands-on demo and
we will first go to the node.js website
nodejs.org we can download the lts
version which is a stable version of
node.js moment i click on this it will
prompt me for a download it will
download the msi file and then all i
need
to do is double click on it keep
clicking on the next button and install
that would install
node.js for us next we'll open our
editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use
an editor called visual studio code and
let's open up
the terminal here and i also have the
command prompt open
where i've navigated to a folder that
i've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command
npx so npx will not only install
packages but also
execute them once they are installed so
once they are downloaded it will execute
the package
and we will use npx to go and create
a react application called client so
while we give it time for the
installation to complete
we can then open it within our editor
so we'll give it time so that the
installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we have seen here that the installation
has now completed and let's
go and open up this project so i will
say file and open folder
and let me pick up that folder and we
will open this application called client
so that's my client app
let's fire up the terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here uh all we need to do to fire up
this application and get it running
is npm start which will compile and
start up this application that is
created
let's close this we'll go to the browser
and now
let's say localhost 3000
so that gives us a startup page the
sample
default startup page for the first
client application uh and this is going
to work as a client we'll now go
and try to create the backend
application which is going to be another
application that we will set up
and to create that let's say npx
express generator api okay so this will
uh
create an express application on node.js
called
api and let's give it some time for
installation okay so that's done
clear this screen we'll come out here
we'll open another instance of the
editor we'll say
open folder and that's the api
application we'll say select folder
and the api application is opened let's
go to the terminal
now in the terminal we will attempt to
install
all of the packages that are required
that would be
logged in the package.json file so the
package.json file here would be
listed so you can see we have a list of
packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here
so let me ensure it's executed
correctly and we'll fire that once more
that's done
so npm install has installed all of the
packages required
and let me terminate this run by
pressing a control
c so this terminates the client
application that was executing
and now we will say npm start
so that this application executes and
let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now
that has got installed now let's go to
the
api application we'll go into the bin
folder
and here we'll have a file called www we
will change
the default port number from 3000 to
9000 let me stop
this application from executing we've
just updated the port number
now let's go to the routes and
we'll create a new file in the routes
folder
called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express and here we'll
say
variable router equal to express
dot router and here we will say
router dot get we'll open this
so that's the default route root route
is going to be slash
for which we'll add a callback function
which will
take the request and the response
parameter
and next pointer in case there is
another function to call
post that and here we will just send a
simple message
saying api is working okay a simple
message sent out
for the root default route and we'll
have to export this so we'll say module
dot
exports equal to router all right so
that's
uh done let's go to the app.js file
and here let us import that so
here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use
the test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name
that we will declare here which will be
equal to
require and we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's
try launching this now we would say npm
start
after adding this code let's go out here
and 3000 test api
is going to be the url to hit it's not
3000 but 9000 now because we just
updated
the port so 9000 test api and there we
have a message which says that the api
is working properly so this is tested
now let's go to
the client application in the client
application let's go to the app.js file
okay this is the file that we would have
to
revamp a bit so let's uh
revamp this here we will declare a class
app which extends so that creates a new
module so it extends react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept
the props here i would pass props to
the superclass constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up
a new function called call api which
will generate a call to that
api url which was http
localhost 9000 was the port and
test api was the url once this is called
we will then call the then function
declare response
generate a call to response.txt and
then we will again say this dot set
state
api response is going to be equal to the
response
that comes in from that url which is
nothing but
a string which says api is working
another function
called component will mount so the
moment the component
is initialized on the screen and loaded
we will generate a call to this
function we created called call api then
comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return
a div class name as app this would be
app header
the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here
right after the header we'll add a
paragraph where we will
print this dot state and the variable we
created called
api response and we will data bind to
that
so that largely completes uh the return
so we simply
create this application uh that's the
react application that will talk to this
api that is
and this uh url that is hosted on node
communicate with it get a simple string
as a response print that string
inside this react application so once
that's done
uh we have the component will mount
which is a life cycle method here it's a
life cycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when
we have actually gone and executed the
call api custom function
let's go to the api application we'll
terminate the execution here there's one
more step
that we'll have to perform which is
cross-origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow
the react application to communicate
from another hosted domain to this
particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from
another application so for that we'll
have to install
globally cross origin module and dash
dash save indicates that it's going to
do a global
install for all applications that are on
this particular system so we've
installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js and
right here is where we would want it
to go and use cards so we will say
app.use
course so that it uses this particular
api
and here is where we will declare
the cause variable and go and import
the new library package that we just
installed which is quartz
so looks good and now let's
fire up this application with an npm
start let's also fire up
client with an npm start and now when
i go and try looking for
localhost 3000 which is the react
application the react application
should go and talk to the api that is
hosted on
node.js which returns to me that string
message
so if i go and ping that api separately
which is localhost 9000 test api
you can see this is a standard message
so here i
directly ping the api that's hosted in
node.js
now we are consuming it through the
react.js application
and if you scroll down you can see the
message returned
from node.js into react saying the api
is working
properly so the practical impact of this
is to actually host
restful services etc on node as a server
and you can go and consume the data that
is returned there could be in string
text or json format directly into the
react.js
acting as a client application hello
this is matthew with simply learn and
today we're going to cover
react with redux so with our session
today we're going to go through it's
going to cover
why you'd want to use redux when you're
building a react solution
what redux is what are the core
principles of redux
and what are those pillars that drive
what you do in redux
and then finally what are the pros and
cons of redux
and after we've gone through the
powerpoint presentation here what we're
going to do is we're actually going to
go
through and actually do a demo of
actually using
uh redux so you can actually see how
this would all look
so why would you use redux well the
reason why you want to use redux
is that redux actually understands and
helps manage the state
of an object and redux was introduced
to help address some problems that
you're having with react
so the state for an object stores values
and properties that belong to components
that could potentially change over time
so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network
uh they could be changes to the
re-render of the component in the
browser
um the object could also then
potentially store multiple
properties and then with redux it
actually takes in and actually will
create
a uh you know take a a large
application that you could create with
app with a react
and breaks it down to several components
instead of having this
massive number of states you have to
manage
and so every time that you you know an
application will then switch
from a current with a react you'd
actually be then changing the states and
this is a really big
problem because when you're like doing
that switching back and forth there is
the potential
for applications to be re-rendered which
reduces the efficiency of your
application
and so this is why redux was introduced
so you know what is redux so redux
is a way to be able to have a
predictable state container for your
javascript applications
and allow you to run your applications
in multiple different environments so
whether it's
a client solution a service solution or
a native app solution
and then more importantly um or one of
the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test
and so with redux you're able to manage
the state of your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
javascript framework or library
and you can actually then store the um
the application
and the components in a state store
which makes it easy to be able to manage
the state of your application
so in simple words redux stores all the
state objects in a single store and
organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application
any changes in the state the application
can be described to the store by the
user
and then it notifies any modifications
made to the state of that
application so let's jump into the key
principles of redux and there's three
key areas i want to focus in
so the first one is that redux provides
a single source of truth um and that
source of truth is being able to store
the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single
store and this makes it easier for you
to debug and inspect
components of your application uh also
enables you to be able to persist your
app stage for development
and improve faster development cycles
the second principle is its state is
read only
and that's why you're able to describe
more effectively what's happening
because it is read only and this ensures
that no events like network callbacks
uh would uh create and any issues
with the code and the re-rendering of
your application
and that object actions are become then
just plain objects
and then finally changes are made with
pure functions and so what do we mean by
this so we can actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with
pure reducers and we'll go into a demo
electron to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts
an accumulation value and then it takes
back and returns
that as a new accumulation and this
allows you to have a
single source of truth value the user
can return the new state objects instead
of mutating to previous state
uh the user can start with a single
reducing as the app grows
it can then split off into a smaller
reducers
and then finally the reducers just
become functions
so let's talk about the pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree
state and there are four key
states there's get state which returns
the current c to the store
and when we actually run the demo later
on you'll be able to see
that we'll be able to open up our
terminal window and be able to
get the state store from our terminal
window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an
action it's the only way to update the
application state
and here we have a action on a button
change
to actually change the state of the
application and then the final two
are subscribe unsubscribe and
these are our ways in which you can
actually change the listener to the
state
so an action is a plain object that
represents an intention
to change the state so with actions you
have payloads of information that send
data
back and forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data
that can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a tight
field that
indicates the type of action that has
been performed
and finally with reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions
sent to the store and so actions only
describe what's happened but don't
describe
the application state change they are
reducer is a function that accepts the
current state and an
action and then returns a new state with
the action performed and then finally
you can use combined reducers utility
which can then combine reduces in an app
into a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because
nothing is perfect so a
pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store
so there's no confusion over where
you're getting your values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome
redux is more stringent about how the
code is organized this makes it
easier to onboard developers because
there is
a very structured way of writing redux
code
this makes it also then easier for the
initial render
which allows you to make your solution
really optimized as an experience
and then finally developers can track
everything that's going on inside the
app in real time
the cons so one of the big cons is
there's no encapsulation so you're using
redux to test out
the code and the writing of your code
but
the component cells can access data and
they there is
potential for security issues you do
have to use boilerplate code so this
kind of takes us back
to the structured code format it is
strict in its setup and it is
memory intensive so with that let's go
in
and look at a demo of using redux
to reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to
show how redux can work first thing we
want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os
and linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version
now there are other versions you can use
but that's one you would want to use
i already have it installed so i just
want to show you how that looks so i'm
just going to go in and put
node version it's going to give me the
version number so that
shows it's installed and we'll also use
npm which is node package manager
because we'll be using that
validate that it's installed by doing
node mpm
version so okay so looking good and
we're gonna go ahead and create a folder
um on our desktop um normally you
wouldn't put
a project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for
an experiment so we're gonna call this
one redux
react is going to be taking a react
project
and we're going to show what it looks
like as a standard project and then what
it will look like
as a project that's being taken through
redux so let's just move our cursor to
the correct folder and so we're going to
go to cd redux react
and there we are in add the correct
folder
using our command prompt you use
terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax
and we're going to do create dash react
dash app so we're going to create a
default
react app and then we'll also install
redux
dash app and these are the two
components that we need to be able to uh
build out our solution one is a
react and it's react.js and the second
is redux
and we hit return and this is going to
go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications
and install them into the folder that we
just created on our desktop
just give that a moment and so it's
installing the
different packages react react dom react
scripts
and there we have everything installed
great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so i'm
going to use visual studio code to do
most of our work here vs code
is open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all leading
platforms it is from microsoft but it is
open source
and uh there's just a ton of stuff here
but we're going to go ahead and
open up the folder we just created on
our desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder we're just
going to get rid of the welcome screen
we don't need that anymore
uh you'll see there's some commands we
use we do uh control plus
i'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
um not an exclamation point so
you'll see that in our project folder we
have all of the
files we need for our solution we have
both the
node modules and then the public files
the product files is just the
application itself so here on the
index.html you see the
index file there and we're going to
actually show what this looks like
inside of a as it's broadcast from a
web browser in a moment now uh we're
going to create a very simple
application here
and the application is going to look
exactly the same in both
um just standard react
and uh redux react it's the optimization
that's gonna be improved
so we just did mpm dash and start it's
gonna take us to local host call on 3000
give it a moment and then we should get
our floating
uh logo showing that the application's
up and running
up there we are we can go ahead and head
and edit app.js to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're gonna go
into appjs
and we are gonna create an application
called new
comp dot js and we actually have some
code that we've already
created that you can download as part of
this application
so but we're just going to type in here
import react
and then component from
[Music]
react so i'm
going to pull in our react library and
we also
import
connect from
react redux
and that's the package that we're
working in
let's terminate the batch job yes
and then rerun
npm install
save react
dash redux
and here we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for the
using the store and reduces in redux
again
the the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution and
this is what redux gives you all right
so we're going to go ahead and we're
gonna go in
and type in class new comp
extends component
and then we're just gonna select our
constructor
props and then we want to add in the
super props
and then this state
[Music]
i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app don't forget to
save your work as you go along
and we're just going to apply some
styles let's just make the
apply some font style
like italics
then we're gonna make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
oh sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
i just have some basic html for where
we're going to place everything we use a
div tag for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call we'll reference
this styles for
this h3 tag
and so our message is gonna be subscribe
to simply learn
this will be create dynamically use our
style
i'm gonna add in a button
click action
subscribe
and nope change too many s's
all right we'll save that
all right save now let's run the script
you guys have js
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
okay rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the newscorp js
component into here
all right
font style here
and
render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's pretty simple little
application
now playing from use code so we'll
actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling two lines of code all right
let's
run that npm
start and here we go
refreshes our page so what we've just
created is a
basic standard state object
and let's see now
oh yeah this is good now we actually can
show you
that we didn't actually write all our
code correctly so let's go back and fix
that
it's newport news
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
uh have a correct export feature here so
that the image
that the everything can be exported
effectively
import we also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our uh problem
hey there we are so welcome and then we
have the
standard state object of subscribe to
simplyline hit subscribe
and we change the text to thank you for
subscribing okay so let's
kind of go in and modify this now so it
goes from being
a standard state object to one that uses
store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job and since you reset
everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good and now we want to
start our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to our index file
index.js
here's our react dom
now we're going to add in contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
now it's going to be a reducer
and we're going to put in
strict mode okay
juice is not defined let's go ahead and
define that
so we're going to come over to our
new comp js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going
to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and just kind of stripping it down here
now let's go in and
let's map our state to
[Music]
props equals
state and we're going to do
return
message is state
dot message
and then
[Music]
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to be in return
and we have our button change
for dispatch
and we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change let's
turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right and now
we actually connect
as part of our export and in our
connection i'm going to do
map state props and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here
so serve to button change we're going to
do props dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and you go ahead and create a new folder
and this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
we're going to call the store reducer.js
and const initial state
equals this is what the default state
will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply then
and then the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and constant new state
and it's going to be an if action
dot type
i'm going to change the message
here's unused comp
so that's the action there we
pull that so it's identical
and then new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so we have the
default now we have the new message
again this might seem like um extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
export default reducer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and now let's
go ahead so we have
let's just inspect everything it's all
looking good
all right now terminal window we're
going to do npm start
let's see what happens and our web
browser should load up
oh we have an error that's good so now
we're learning stuff
and this again this is all part of your
standard coding is just
hunting down errors in your code so
let's go to index.js
and looks like
we're going to pull in here so we have
reduce
and this should actually be spelled
correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back recompile
let's rerun uh
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be trying mainstream
provider
[Music]
store
is referenced correctly
okay let's re-run our application
and there we are
so let's go back through
our application is running much faster
now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our
applications different objects we're
able to change the messages after you
click
and it's able to then create the new
message again this is a very simple
application but you can see how for
more complex solutions how this becomes
useful and you can start using the
different components you create
for your whole solution and that's our
demo
welcome to this session on react native
versus flutter in this session we would
look at
identifying some of the differences
between
the react native and flutter frameworks
let's start with understanding the core
areas of comparison
as part of this session we will be
looking at
key aspects to identify differences
between both the frameworks
predominantly on the language front the
ui
aspect the performance the documentation
the popularity the community support
that is available
for both these frameworks along with
the industry trends in terms of the
industry adoption for both these
platforms the core objective of the
session
would be that at the end you should be
able to decide
and make an informed decision as to
which framework is the best
among those available let's start from a
language perspective
now if you look at react react is
basically completely
written and built in javascript
using the react.js api on the other hand
if you look at flutter it is basically
written
in a very new language called as start
and we do not have
uh too many developers that are skilled
on dart
however uh every browser and every
platform
being shipped with uh an inbuilt
javascript
execution environment that makes
javascript
platform the language of choice for
developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer
would have inbuilt support for executing
javascript programs similarly most
popular platforms mobility platforms
like android and
ios have default support for executing
javascript programs and that's the
reason when you compare this with
flutter flutter uses dart which is
predominantly a newer
language and we really do not have too
many developers who are skilled on this
so actually is the selling point and the
usb of react
native because when you work with react
native uh you really do not have to
relearn a lot you don't have a sharp
learning curve
most of the javascript developers who
are working with means tag
already working with html css and dhtml
can easily align to this that as we have
discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have
that much of penetration in the
developer community
from a ui perspective when you talk
about react native
it's based pretty much on native
components for the android and the ios
platform
and flutter on the other hand uses a
very proprietary
set of widgets and it has its own page
structure
that needs to be set up so it's a closed
ecosystem as compared to an open
ecosystem in react native which allows
you to go and implement third party
widgets and ui frameworks as well now
this is really what
allows you to pick and choose with react
native because you can go
and decide whether you want to use kendo
ui or a set of telerik controls or any
other third party
ui framework can be implemented but for
flutter you have
a pretty closed ecosystem and that's the
reason the ui components
that are available out of the box and
built into the
platform are all that you can use from a
performance perspective
when you talk about react native it
basically
is built and uses javascript out of the
box and that's the reason
when you want to write any code in
javascript that connects and tries to
access
native services on that specific
platform it uses a bridge
to do that but when you're using flutter
on the other hand
flutter does not need any kind of bridge
so there's no
concept of you write flutter code and
then it uses a bridge to go and
connect to the native set of components
to interact with and this is what really
impacts the speed and the performance
aspect of developing and executing
applications
between both these frameworks because if
you look at react the speed of
development is a little bit
slower when you compare that with
flutter
and that's because it has an
intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and
every layer of additional communication
and computation that you put
in between two tiers in a application
that you built
obviously would have a performance
impact
from a documentation perspective if we
were to compare flutter
typically has a very well defined
documentation repository and
it allows developers to go through it in
a very simple manner so it's all
structured it's all
organized unlike what you see on react
native because in react native it
actually
since react native is an open ecosystem
and allows you to implement third party
widgets and you can do a lot of
configuration and plug and play
and that's the reason uh the
documentation also is not very strong
well organized and impactful and that's
the reason uh
most developers would find it a little
challenging to go through
the react native documentation when you
compare that
to the documentation available in terms
of flutter popularity is always a key
when working with
platforms and that should be a crucial
decision maker because
when it comes to open source
technologies and you're stuck somewhere
you obviously go to the commit to the
community to go and find out how best
you can
solution the problem now flutter being
relatively
a new entrant into the market it does
not have a lot of developer
penetration and that's the reason the
popularity in the community is not very
strong react
natively there for a while now it's been
around for some time and that's the
reason
uh it's pretty popular among developers
also since
uh it uses javascript it's a natural
transition and a progression
path for those who are working with
html5 css building web applications
or have been building hybrid mobile apps
find it very easy
to migrate to this because flutter
requires you to learn a new programming
language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this
is much much better on the react native
front as compared to
flutter again if you look at google
trends
you could actually look at both of the
lines here the red line
indicating flutter it started on a very
positive note
and then there was a plateau and then
suddenly a spike
react native has been much more steady
in terms of its growth
and ultimately if you look at it now
both of them
seem to be trending at par with each
other
so the community support as we were
speaking about if you look at stack
overflow which is
one of the most popular websites to go
for any kind of
uh developer trends and movements and
for a q a that most developers would
have you can actually look at the number
of questions here
and uh also react native is
part of github as it's open source it
was released in
2015 and uh it's because of the
huge community support that it becomes
uh easier to implement this
you have a lot of confidence as a
developer when you start building on
this stack
because if you're stuck somewhere you
will have a lot of help available on the
way
on the other hand if you compare that
with flutter you can look at the
question
count here on stack overflow and this
being a new entrant in the market
uh it has a smaller footprint on the
community
aspect but of course that keeps
increasing every day
again from a react native perspective
and you talk about stability in terms of
stable releases
uh there again you would see that react
native does a much better job as
compared
to flutter so the industry tents are
something which
all of us have to be aware of
specifically if we would need to make a
decision in terms of our careers
the technology that we are learning what
is the growth aspect
what is the industry adoption and how we
could really
move ahead on our career graphs in terms
of the
opportunities market the job market etc
so again getting back to stack overflow
which is the benchmark for
understanding technology trends in ide
sphere and software development if you
look at a recent survey conducted in
2019
uh 62.5 percent of developers uh
seem to have shown interest in react
native
as compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much
better and of course that could be due
to the uh
time frames that uh both these
technologies uh
have been around react has been around
for quite a while and hence the job
prospects are much better
a lot of organizations implementing this
clutter has been a new entrant and hence
uh
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen
in the opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react
native india implementations right from
facebook to pinterest to wix
skype tesla insta bloomberg
you can actually look at the
implementation across industry which is
absolutely
crucial when you're learning something
new because when you want to join a
large logo obviously
if there are a lot of logos using this
that enhances the credibility of your
learning
puts a justification to why you would
want to learn this technology flutter on
the other hand
associated with big names like google
sonos alibaba the largest retailer out
there
from a conclusion perspective if we were
to conclude on what we've discussed from
a language
perspective obviously we said react is
much more popular since it
is a natural progression for developers
to work on javascript and move to this
as compared to dart which is relatively
a new language
from a ui perspective the open source
plug-and-play capability of configuring
and adopting
seamlessly to newer platforms of widgets
and third-party ui platforms are much
better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on
inbuilt widgets to implement the
performance aspect we discussed because
of the bridge
from the code that you write to the
native component access
exists in react and is isolated and not
any longer required in flutter and hence
the performance is impacted because of
the additional layer in between
the documentation much much better in
flutter because it's a closed ecosystem
and they can control
what you can use react native being
open-ended it really
has a lot of third-party integration you
can do and hence the documentation is
not really well
organized the popularity perspective
react native
much more popular among html5 css three
mer
mean stack developers since it's all
javascript
flutter needs you to learn new skills
and you need to spend additional time
for that
from a community support react native
has been there for a longer time as
compared to flutter and hence
has a stronger community support as
compared to flutter
and that translates into better job
prospects
in the industry for react native as
compared to flutter so if we were to
give it a score
react scores much better with a total
score of 5
leaving flutter with a total score of 2.
so i hope we were able to understand
the differences between the react native
and flutter
and this will help you make better
decisions with planning your career and
deciding which technology
you should latch on so our demo is going
to be about creating
a calculator using react and node.js
and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy
um but the whole thing is going to be
created with react and so be using
javascript to be installing react
and installing the various components
such as node.js
and the different npm solutions that we
need so as you can see
my calculator works just fine and now
let's go ahead
and let's go and
install the different tools that we need
so the first one is going to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things
and so we go to the default node.js site
and you can go to downloads and there
are windows mac os
and also linux installers you can also
download the original source code and
compile it yourself if you want
and you'll also need a text editor i'm
going to be using visual studio code
it's just my favorite text editor it's
free works across all platforms
uh it comes with a ton of extensions so
you can get up and running really
quickly with it
um so we're just going to go ahead and
install the windows version i already
have installed so you have to
download it again you also want to make
sure that you have the latest version
of node.js installed now with that node
package manager so we're just going to
open up our terminal window and validate
which version that we have
running and
we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node version
and it'll tell us which version and
which means that's installed and the
same thing with npm
node package manager will do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to
uh do that and we're going to also now
create a react app so we're going to do
install and then it's gonna be create
dash react dash app
that's the command to create a new react
app
and we're gonna install it right off our
desktop
so let's go in and we'll put mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install
a folder on our desktop with all the
appropriate react
code and this will be just a
template application but it'll have
everything there that we need to get
started with
hit return and that'll take a few
minutes just to install everything
here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component
and they'll be the main component that
has all the information that will
then be disabled on the screen then we
have a layout component
and that will be the actual look and
feel of the calculator
and the output component which will be
the results from the calculator
and then the output row and this will be
all the different tools that we will
need and here we have
uh our new folder right there
uh on our desktop um but we're actually
gonna go now into visual studio
and if you've seen any of the other
node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to
work with the node.js in visual studio
code
um because i can run terminal window
right there so i'm going to open up the
folder that we just created
that's called calculator and we open up
the whole folder
not a file but the whole folder and
here's our folder on the left hand side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for
what the calculator looks like
including which version of react and the
dom
and here's our default uh element
as you can see because we're using react
it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div
with the id of root that's going to
reference um
some class files that we create and so
the app.js file has the application
code that we're going to be modifying in
a little bit and you'll see that
it actually then references
up to our index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the
id element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so
we're constantly referencing and
cross-referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
uh npm
and it's now going to have everything
running on
let's have localhost and everything
running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the
standard default react boilerplate
app it's just taking a moment to
load i should probably get a faster
computer
okay there we are uh just not patient
so here we have our basic boilerplate
react js
application nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code
so uh see now yep everything's running
where we expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and we can actually go ahead and if you
want to type control plus c
and actually stop the app or you can um
uh in the terminal window you can
actually stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message
there we go site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in and
we're going to just restart our
application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page and
we'll
see our default react app
coming up on port 3001
and there we are
looking good looking good
okay so we're going to delete out what
we have there because we want to put in
our own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be
modifying that class here in just a
moment i'm putting a default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there i'm going to
call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
say import
layout and then
we want to do the path to our layout
components layout you need so we have
the dot because we have to go up one
folder that's the command for that
so dot up one folder components folder
layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the js extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
do this using css
then we're going to import react
from react
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css it's going to be a css file that
we're going to create
so we're gonna have to type that into
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so here we have
and then we're going to put in
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up correctly
okay so go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our pathing here just
quite quickly
so let's
[Music]
we're gonna move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
we run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
uh yep i know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in some values
here
so that the application knows to lay
content out so we just put in
a hello world
there we are okay so that shows us
everything is pulling through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this div
so that actually starts pulling in the
application
and put in the class name for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay so you need to have some image
files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a css file that
we'll use to create these elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but as bottom line is that
the calculator really is a bunch of
form elements such as buttons
on the screen but we use css to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications
is how to take technologies that you're
used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look
different and so in this instance we're
used to using
button elements within an application so
why not use the the same button elements
which
consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply update the look and
feel of them with some css so that
they they look good and here we are just
doing a very simple
on click command um this is
some basic javascript that will
render inside of the browser itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying
that the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's delete now we have an unclick
event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here making sure
everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign
and then the forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
it's got a new row here
i'm just gonna copy everything over just
make it a little bit easier ourselves
and then we're just going to find pin
the numbers
7 8 9
and then
plus single sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep going through
making all the changes here so we
actually fill out all the different
elements
so as you can see most of this isn't
really
complex it's just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen we start seeing
all the different elements
okay i can get it
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
so now
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we do that in our layout.css file
and so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the for the sake of brevity
we're just going to
pull those over
we can if you want to and have us do
a more detailed video on how to create
the csc
css files and you know we'll certainly
do that but i think most you probably
know how to do this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the
border color et cetera et cetera and so
we're going to do that
here we have our
buttons for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css then we just
have basic buttons
we have the css link back in we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
default logo so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets and the assets will put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
then we'll create another folder we'll
call this one
images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn
logo
and then for layout we can then just
reference that in our image reference
so i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder and under assets we'll
go to amg which we have our image
and then we'll do the path for the
logo.png
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is from
our logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
i'll put the width and we have to know
it's 150 pixels
and the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
css
will be
block so just some inline styling here
generally normally do this i normally
have all my styling in my css
folder um but uh in this instance
because we're just
putting up a solution i want you to be
able to see that you can actually do
this
in line so there we are i have our
simplyland logo
okay so now we need to have the results
screen
make sure that looks correct
okay and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to be got our
output js file and this is going to
control the output in that blue
screen
and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we'll put a new file called output
row
dot js we'll put our instructions
uh this is going to be our component the
users will put their
results into
and now put row
and we're gonna put our instructions
here
so we're gonna like export default
output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct
our solution and we're going to update
the
output row.js file and
we're going to add in
our return value
so put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field um
that will be read only at the top
of our calculator and here we see our
text field here
and that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
you our formatting
and we're going to put a file it's going
to be output row.css we're going to add
in our
specific css for
this output row
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard html5
skill sets here
and let's go over to our
style it will pull in
our props dot text size
and then the default value
and so this is going to align with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will play in our output row
and the value will be
we bring that text size for output flow
here
[Music]
and we're just going to put some sample
css styling here
nothing too crazy
and we have two rows
save that
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output
pulling those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be the calculation
broken out as we've written it and the
bottom row will be the results and it's
going to our css file here we're going
to copy over some css
and you have some
font styling we have our screen class
name
there's our screen here again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
um editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
you can see they're referring to a font
asset we actually have the font in there
we have to
pull that font over and
it's just a ttf font true type font
now you can use and any of the uh
internet fonts as well
google has a massive library of fonts
and there we are i'm going to change the
size of
our font so that's the second row the
text
is a little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet
we'll do that in a moment that'll be the
easy part of this assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so net input
set input
and use state
that way we can default the initial
state
and for the result the you state
the initially state will be just blank
there we are just what you'd expect to
see
so the results um are blank and this is
just when you run the app for the very
first time
okay so going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
you want to take the value of the button
and so it's you're going to be
any of these actions here
and we're just going to put together a
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far we've put most
of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base
react application putting together the
different files and folder structure um
making sure we have the correct assets
such as
images fonts
css files um laying out
our core structure in html form elements
and now the part that we're doing at the
end here
is putting together the script that will
actually
write that actually do our calculator
events and and honestly and this is
going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are
lots of javascript calculators on the
internet so you can actually take any of
those
and use those as a base
for what we're doing here there we have
it if there's an error we'll do math
error a result
we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
so our different results
so depending on
which commands you use so for instance
it's the equal sign and
have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be seeing in
which screen
okay that's looking good
so we'll capture our value and
this is all concatenate together and
if there are any error messages
so if the value is c from the button so
if we set
c
so we want to set the input to 0 which
is to reset
the screen
and if the value
equals and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to eliminate
the last character entered
and this is manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard javascript
control so
hit delete and that gets rid of a
character
another character hit it again i'll get
rid of the
third character
[Music]
and
put if the string is
zero then put that as the value
all right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values
correctly
and here we have the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always
want to go back and double check that
you have all your commands
or your variables lining up correctly
eliminate those
now we'll make sure we have the answer
and the
user entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that we'll go over this is
now this is our local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of
both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and
this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see everything lined up
correctly and so you've seen how in just
45 minutes you can actually
write out your own
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created
we'll restart the services
say yes i'm running on another port
because we already have an app running
on
another port so it's going to run on
3001
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application
up and running everything
looks really good working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application
and make it a native application as well
right now we're just using as a web
application
we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything looking exactly the same
there you go that's your app all up and
running
welcome to the session on react.js
interview questions
through this session we will explore the
most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to
a developer interview on react.js let's
start with going through
and exploring the general set of
react.js
interview questions that would be
commonly asked in an interview the first
question would be
what are the features of react.js now
right through this
session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore
the question and then look at the best
way in which
you could have answered that question if
posed to you
during a react.js interview so starting
with the first question
what are the features of react so react
has many extensions
for complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe
what the user interface should typically
look like
react is broken into small components
so you look at the complete application
you want to build break it down
into individual components and a
component is typically a piece of user
interface
like a function that would return a
stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react
as only the updated components need to
be re-rendered on the screen and not the
entire page
the one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast
the virtual dom is also a lightweight
representation
of the real dom which is again a feature
which helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full
dom tree shake which really speeds up
performance so what is jsx how do you
answer this
so jsx is typically the extension used
for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use
inside your browser for execution
typically has to be javascript because
in html5 you cannot have any third-party
plugins installed in the browser and
that's the reason the browser would only
ship by default with a javascript
runtime engine so by using jsx
you can write html structures in the
same file
that would contain your javascript code
as well making the
updates to the code very simple so it's
simple to update and make modifications
to your code because the code and the
data and the business logic is all
composed in
a single file so because the code and
the business logic is in a single file
it makes
uh updating and incorporating change
requests
to the code very simple and easy so it's
basically used
with react to describe what your user
interface should look like and
it's what you typically would term as
the html template or the view
coming to the next question can jsx be
directly
read by the web browser so web browsers
cannot
read jsx directly now why is that well
the reason is simple it's because they
are only built
to read regular javascript objects and
jsx
is not a regular javascript objects it's
a react
component so for a web browser to read a
jsx file the file needs to be
transformed
into a regular javascript object and for
this there is
a javascript api called people which is
internally used by react
so what do you understand by the virtual
dom that we've been speaking about
in react so react gives a very
lightweight representation of the real
dom the actual dom structure of the page
so dom
is document object model it is an api
created by w3c and it creates an
in-memory representation
of the html elements as an inverted tree
structure a balanced tree structure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for html
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic dom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh
and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in
it uses a virtual dom which is a layer
on top of the actual dom which ensures
that only a certain part
of the page is refreshed and that speeds
up performance
so when the state of an object changes
virtual dom changes only that object in
the real dom instead of updating all the
objects and this
is what makes things really fast so why
use react instead of other frameworks
like angular first of all
it's very easy to create dynamic web
pages
dhtml where you can update the view or
the template
at runtime the components are reusable
so you reuse rather than reinvent the
performance is great
since you're working with the virtual
dom you don't need a full page refresh
the unidirectional data flow makes data
move one way
there's no two-way data binding by
default and that's the reason the page
does not have to do a lot of heavy
lifting of remembering whether the view
is changing whether the the base
javascript
entity class is changing and that saves
a lot of uh
processing time again to debug react is
much more simpler and that's what makes
it more popular
in terms of its simplicity and speed as
compared to other frameworks like
angular what is the difference
between es5 and es6
standard so these are scripting
standards okay that are
defined by the european computer
manufacturers association or ecma
and all of the scripting languages are a
subset of the standard and
are derived from these standards to
ensure that the code will execute on all
browsers and the code that we are
writing is standards based
so these are the few instances where es6
syntax has changed from es5 if you look
at the es5 first syntax at the top we're
creating a simple
react class component and the render
function just returns a stream of
html content in ex6 there's a new
keyword
that comes in which is extends so you
are extending
from the base react component and
creating a custom component and then
returning a stream of characters also
the function keyword no longer
needs to be used so the exports versus
export also changes so you use exports
to export
out class from a module so that it can
be accessed from another module in es6
you simply say export and the component
require versus import so you would
require
a third party component or an api into
your javascript file to use it
in es6 it's replaced with the import
statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in code java so how do you go and create
a react app first you install node.js as
a base platform which you can download
from the node.js website
next any text editor of your choice
could be atom visual studio code
or sublime text third you create a react
app using a command prompt
terminal depending on the os you are
using the command to give
is create hyphen react space my first
app okay so the command
that you would give to create a new
react app is create
hyphen react hyphen app space and the
name of the application you would want
to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice
so what is an event in react well on the
web when you talk about dynamic
html it's all about interacting with the
user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action
uh can be triggered by a user or any
system or
could be pressing a key or a mouse click
etc and in response to that event you
would execute a block of code
which is called an event handler so here
we have class simple which is a custom
class that extends
the base react component the name of the
function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box
and a render function which returns html
when you click on the button
we would want to bind that to the event
handler
this dot work and that's how you connect
a click event
to an event handler function what are
synthetic events in react
well a synthetic event is an object
which acts as a cross browser wrapper
around
the browser's native event it combines
the behavior of different browser's
native events into one api
which makes sure that the events are
consistent across different browsers and
this brings in the standards based
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating
for different browsers have consistency
in terms of its execution so here we see
a function
action link we see a function handle
click which takes e
as an event parameter e dot prevent
default ensures that there is
no error that the browser is raising in
case the event
function call is not directly compatible
with that specific browser so prevent
default is used
to suppress any browser specific errors
or crashes and a simple console.lock
which will lock
into the developer tools window which
says you just clicked a link and then
we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to or the html template
where on click we connect to this event
handler called handle click
so handle click is basically a wrapper
and the entire action link
is a wrapper object which is a synthetic
event
we don't directly go and bind to
the on click and then associate a
function with it we
actually associate a synthetic object
with it which binds the base
default event that could be specific to
a browser so some browsers would
probably understand an on click sun
another browser would understand
a click and to ensure that it's
consistency of syntax and from a
development perspective the code that we
write
will run on all browsers we need to take
care of
using the synthetic events which isolate
the developer out from the complexity of
writing code specific to different
browsers so you just
write generic code which will work on
different browsers
so how do lists work in react so the
list display data in an ordered format
the traversal of lists is done
using the map function so here we see
there is a function called list of names
which takes
a variable props as a parameter props
dot names
will allow us to get a reference to all
of the
array of names that are passed constant
list names is another variable
created equal to name start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard
and again we are using the opening tag
of the
li html element the key is equal to the
name attribute so the brace bracket will
bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the ally tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an
unordered list the list names themselves
so the map function will run through an
iterate over the list of names
list them in the li tag the li tag will
get injected into
the unordered list and will finally get
returned out as a stream of html
elements
in the next code snippet below we create
a constant variable names we are
associating it with a set of
five names and we simply say render
list of names names equal to names the
moment we do that
we are using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names added to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a forward loop that you would
write for iteration
in other programming languages and then
finally what you get returned in the get
element by id app
is nothing but a list of simple names
wrapped in a li element that are printed
on the view so why is there a need of
using keys
in lists so keys are very important in
the code snippet that we saw
due to the following reasons the first
reason the key is a unique identifier if
you would want to
search for a name in the list it is used
to identify which items have changed
updated or deleted
from the list so if you want to perform
clutter operations on the
data you would want to search for which
element do you want
to update or delete or change it also
helps to determine which components need
to be re-rendered
instead of re-rendering all the
components every time
and it increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not
all the components on the page what are
forms in react
so using forms users can interact with
the application
and enter required information whenever
needed so forms can contain certain
elements such as text fields buttons
checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as
user authentication searching filtering
etc how do you create a form pretty
simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend reactor
component
we create a state variable this dot
state is equal to
value we handle the change by writing a
handle change event and we handle the
submit by writing a handle submit event
in the change event we just change the
state by saying set state of the value
to event.target.value event being a
system defined keyword passed as a
parameter
and in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trap the
value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from raising any errors
on the render function we return a form
on the submit we connect to the handle
submit event
and we bind the data submitted from the
form to the handle submit event
and we pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current
context of the view itself we open a
label specify the name
we then specified input box as text the
value is set to this dot state dot value
and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself
so the moment we change the value in the
text box as we are typing
the handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button
the handle submit event handler executes
and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box
and that's it so how do you write
comments in react
when you're a developer if you want to
comment out some code or if you want to
set
comments to enhance the maintainability
of the code a single line comment
is as simple as given in most other
programming languages backslash asterisk
to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do
and what are the types that it can
return what is the arrow function and
how is it used
so an arrow function is a shorter way of
writing a function in react
if you look at the snippet on the top my
input on change equal to
we are connecting to this dot handle
change dot
bind and that's the longer version of
how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to
e arrow operator this dot handle on
change so you don't need to call the
bind explicitly you can replace that
with the arrow operator and reduce the
amount of code that you typically write
how is react different from react native
so
react and react native are completely
different react was released in 2013
it's a web-based platform it is html
compliant
it generates html views it uses css for
styling and it's based on javascript
html and css
react native on the other hand is
targeted to mobility devices
it's meant to create installable apps on
android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css
and it basically requires the react.js
api to create these installable apps for
these mobility ecosystems how is react
different from angular another popular
framework by google so angular created
by google
completely based on the model view
controller pattern works on the real dom
layer and requires a full tree
shake at the tom layer to update views
and components
supports bi-directional data mining the
rendering is purely done on the client
side the performance comparatively slow
react.js on the other hand created by
facebook it's the view layer
of the model view controller pattern it
works at the virtual
dom layer and it sends faster it's
unidirectional
data binding and not two-way and the
rendering is typically what is done
at the server side and what you get as a
response on the client as a stream of
html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components
so what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small
parts each part identifying a certain
solution
of the problem which is what we define
as a component so they are building
blocks of a react application and a
single app usually consists of
multiple components so it splits the ui
into independent reusable pieces that
can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of
the user interface or the html view what
is the use of
render method in react so it is
compulsory for each component to have a
render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render
on your view so the render function
returns the html which is to be
displayed
within a component like you see on the
screen there is a class app that extends
the react component
and it returns a simple h1 element
called hello
simply learn and of course do remember
to export
the app out so that it can be accessed
from other components as well if you
need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a
single parent tag like a div or a form
what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds
some data within it the data would
influence
the output of the component now how do
you
implement state in react so state
holds the data that a component renders
on the web application for example here
we have created in the constructor this
dot state
equal to and this temporary anonymous
object has two
attributes car and pi when we return we
simply return
this dot state dot car and this dot
state
dot by now this is how you would create
stateful components and access the state
properties within the view how do you
update the state of a component
by using the built-in set state method
you can go ahead and update the state
of the component so here we have a
simple render function that returns
the state itself state dot message and
on the on click connects to a button
press
function the moment you click on the
button the button press function
sets the state to another message so the
initial message in the constructor is
welcome to simply learn
the moment you click on the button the
set state triggers and changes it
to best place to learn so the data on
the view would be
updated what are props in react well
props is just a short
form for properties and that is what
allows us to pass arguments or
data to a component props are passed to
components
in the way similar to that of attributes
that are passed to an html element
so how do you pass props between two
components so let's say we have an
app.js component on the top and a
main.js component
at the bottom at the top we are trying
to return this dot props dot
car and the pike so two car and bike
attributes
associated with this props of the app
component in the main component when you
look at the render function
we are associating car prop equal to a
value of 1 600 cc and bike prop
equal to value of 150cc
and to access it if you look at the
import statement we are importing app
from app.jsx and this is how you can
cross-access
properties from one component within the
other so what are the difference between
state and props
well state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed
they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot
have state props allow to pass data from
one component to the other
as an argument they are immutable they
are read only and props can be accessed
by the child component and they can
have props as well what is a higher
order component in react so these act as
a container
for other components which helps in
keeping components simple
and induces the reusability factor
they are generally used when a common
logic has to be used by multiple
components that's when you group
together a set of components within a
higher order
component in react how can you embed two
or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns
a hello text and it has a custom tag
called simple
the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns
text called simply learn and in the
render of the react dom
we simply go and render the app
component so hello
simply learn would be the final output
and that's how you can embed
one component into the other using this
methodology what are the differences
between class and functional components
so stateful components would extend
react component in this case
and if you could look at the render it
simply renders this.props.title
the constant stateless component would
be equal to props
the div tag returns this dot props dot
title so you can look at the style
very different in terms of class and
functional components
one using the arrow operator one using
the traditional class and render method
so the class component can hold or
manage state
complex as compared to stateless
components can work
all of the life cycle methods of the
component and it can be reused
the functional component cannot hold a
managed state they are simple and easy
to understand it does not work with any
life cycle method and it cannot be
reused
let's explain the lifecycle methods of
components we've got kennish initial
state
which is executed before the creation of
the component
component did mount which is executed
when the component gets rendered and
placed on the dom
should component update which is invoked
when a component decides
any changes to the dom and returns true
or false
value based on certain conditions
component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place
component will unmount which is invoked
immediately before a component is
destroyed and unmounted
permanently let's move to the react
redux set of questions
so what is redux it's an open source
javascript library used to manage
application state and react uses redux
for building the user
interface what are components of redux
the first
is the store which holds the state of
the application store contains state
which defines the user interface which
triggers a set of actions which are then
sent
to the reducer so store holds the state
action is the source information for the
store and reducer specifies how the
application state changes
in response to actions sent to the store
what is flux
well flux is the application
architecture that facebook uses for
building
web applications and it works in this
way the action is triggered which is
sent to the dispatcher the dispatcher
sends it to the store
the store sends it to the view and the
view
sends it back to the action and that's
exactly how the steps would continue in
sequence
so when we trigger an action the
dispatcher will get notified once the
dispatcher has dealt with an action the
stores
listening to it will get triggered the
view gets updated when the state
of the store changes user action at the
view
is sent to the dispatcher to then be
processed how is redux different
from flux redux is an open source
javascript library used to manage
application state
the store state is immutable it can only
have a single store
and it uses the concept of reducer flux
on the other hand is an architecture and
not a framework or library
the store state is mutable it can have
multiple stores
and it uses the concept of dispatcher
let's look at some react
router questions what is a react router
a react router is a package which is
used to create routing in a react
application
react router is used for developing
single page web applications it allows
multiple views
in a single application by defining
multiple routes
in that react application how is react
routing different from conventional
routing
react routing has a single html page it
uses
or the end user rather would navigate
multiple views
within the same file called a single
page app the page does not refresh since
it's a single page file
and there is improved performance since
you are not navigating across multiple
pages
conventional routing each view is a
separate html file the user would
navigate
multiple files for each view the page
would refresh
every time the user navigates which
would hence result in slower performance
how do you implement react routing you
can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components
let's say you've got a component called
app about and contact
so here you can specify the route path
if the route part
is just slash the route defaults out it
takes you to the app component
if the route is slash about in the url
given by the end user you automatically
navigate and activate and load
the about component and if the url is
slash contact it would take you to the
contact component
let's talk about react styling questions
how do you style react components
either you use inline styling by using
simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1
element or i could use a javascript
object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color
background color margin font family and
apply that object
as the style parameter which would
result in this
styled output how do you style react
components using a css style sheet so
here's an external style sheet so we've
written all the styling rules in a
separate css
file app.css we've imported that at the
top of the
app.js react class and lo and behold you
have the output
simplified as generated on your page
let's explain the use
of css modules in react so a css module
file
is created.module.css is the
extension the css inside a module file
is available only for the component that
is
importing it so there are no naming
conflicts so dot button
is the css styling inside
button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button
style start button is the styling picked
up from the button.module.css
file file alright so that is it for this
complete react crash course
if you liked the video give it a thumbs
up and hit the subscribe button and the
bell icons
to never miss an update thank you for
being here keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here
you